بالنسبه للتوراه مثلا لا توجد ترجمه عربيه
للتوراه قام بها مسلمون
الى الان في التسعينات كان في اسرائيل
حوالي 35 مركز للدراسات العربيه الاسلاميه
يهتم من المغرب الى تشقن هذا هو الذي
يجعلني في هذه السن اشعر بالاحباط
لانني
اعرف ما الذي سيحدث في المستقبل
هذا التقصير الذي طال سيؤدي الى
وخيم العوائق ولذلك اقول دائما لطلبتي
هذا الهيكل سيبنى الهيكل هذا سيبنى على
انقاذ المسجد الاقصى هذه حتميه تورتي
وحتميه يهوديه يجب ان يفهم العرب هذا
يجب نفهم السياسيون هذا لانه جزء من
الشرائع اليهوديه معطل
اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد الرحمن
ابو مالح اليهود
من هم
كيف ينظرون لنا نحن المسلمين
وبماذا يؤمنون وما علاقتهم بالمسلمين
وايش وجه الاختلاف بيننا وبينهم قبل
احتلال فلسطين
بينما تلاقي الاف الدراسات والابحاث عن
العرب والمسلمين في اسرائيل لما عندنا الا
مراكز ابحاث اقل من اصابع اليد الواحده
تدرس اليهود واسرائيل يقول ضيفي فوزي
البدوي لما اراد العرب فهم اليهوديه بعد
استعادوا الجدل القديم بين الاسلام
واليهوديه في القرون الوسطى لكن اللي ما
ادرك العرب ان اسرائيل بعد 67 تختلف بشكل
جذري تقريبا عن اليهوديه التي عرفوها في
القرون الوسطى
فهذه الحلقه عن اليهود كما هم يرون انفسهم
من نشاتهم وحتى
احتلالهم لفلسطين لماذا اختاروه فلسطين من
بين كل الدول وكيف نشات الصهيونيه
وايش سر الصح والدينيه اللي صارت عندهم
بعد حرب 67
والاسئله كثيره
وجواب الضيف غزير وشافي تكتشف في وسط هذه
الحلقه ان اسرائيل بدون دستور واسرائيل
بدون حدود ان اصل الصهيونيه مسيحيه وانها
بدات دوله بعيده تماما عن الدين واليوم
باتت فيه قمه التقاء القوميه مع الدين هل
قام مع ضيفي الدكتور فوزيه البدوي استاذ
الدراسات اليهوديه ورئيس قسم مقارنه
الاديان بكليه الاداب والفنون والانسانيات
في تونس يقول ان نشات الكيان الصهيوني
وللحركه الصهيونيه تحتاج من العرب
والمسلمين فهم هذه المسجدات بطريقه علميه
واذا لم يفهموها ازعم انها ستكون خطيره
العواقب على وجودهم
قبل ان نبدا في حلقه سابقه بتكون مفيده
وممتعه ومكمله لهذا الموضوع عن علاقه
اليهود بنشاه الحضاره الغربيه مع الدكتور
سعد البازعي ورابط الحلقه في وصف الحلقه
اما الان
لنبدا
ما مدافع منكم
للعاميه في السعوديه لا واضحه واضحه انا
عندي مشكله مع البنغاليين
اللغه المكسره يعني الانجليزيه
لا اعرف باي لغه يتكلم
ان جزء كبير من اللهجه التونسيه هو حجازي
يعني
الكلمه موجوده في تونس موجوده في ليبيا
بكيفيه اخرى بالجزائر ولكن اصولها كلها
مثلا نعطيك مثل الخبز راح نقول الخبز خلاص
في شمال تونسي يقولوا الكسره كسره عندما
تقرا الجاحظ اقل كسره الكسره هي الخبز فكل
يعني هي هي كلمات من العربيه بعضها مهمل
في مكان بعضها مهجور في مكان مشهور في
مكان اخر فما فيش يعني العجيب كيف يمكننا
نتحدث في الموضوع هذا الاسبوع الماضي كيف
ان الليبيين او اللهجه الليبيه قريبه جدا
من اللهجه في الجزيره العربيه
واللهجه التونسيه التونسيه يعني
تكلمت بالعاميه التونسيه يصعب علي فهمك
في بعض كلمات في بعض المغرب
تتغير الامور اكثر ولكن شوف ليبيا مقسومه
الى ثلاثه في المكان اللي هو قريب من مصر
بنغازي فاللهجه متاثره اكثر باللهجه
القريبه للمصري ولكن طرابلس
لهجه طرابلسيه غرب ليبيا وتونس تقريبا
في الجنوب يعني في في جنوب في جنوب ليبيا
انا مشهورين بكلمه يعيشك عيشك
يعيشك كنت مره في جامعه محمد الخامس في
الرباط واتحدث مع صديق مغربي ومررنا بجانب
قاعه يدرس المغربي يدرس
تكلمتني من غيب عشان قلت له عيشك صديقي
المغربي فخرج الاستاذ المغربي قال في
تونسي
[ضحك]
خاصيه تونسيه
الله يعينك والله
يعني موضوع اليهود من مواضيع اللي كنا
نتكلم عنها يعني في فنجان تكلمنا اكثر من
مره عن اللي ودنا نشرح الاشياء الناس
تعتقد انها تفهمها وهي ما تفهم هذا انها
علم ما اخذت السياق الكامل اللي فاهم هذه
المواضيع سواء من مناطق الجغرافيه او بعض
المفاهيم او بعض الاديان مثلا اتكلمنا
مثلا عن السودان يظهر انه العرب يعرفون
بعض بس يوم تحدثنا عن السودان مثلا كانت
موضوع يعني
تكشفت معلومات ومعرفه عن السودان
تخليك تفهم السودان بشكل مختلف
برضه اشتغلنا على الصومال دوله دوله حتى
احيانا داخل السعوديه ففي حلقه كانت عن
عسير رائع جدا فمنطقه
في فهم هذه الاشياء واحس دائما هذه تفيد
الناس
واليهوديه
واسرائيلي من مواضيع
لطالما نتكلم عنها ونبحث عن احد مهتملها
لكن ما يعني يبدو ان العرب متوجسين من
اليهود فرصه تكون فرصه جيده للحديث هذا
الموضوع
وباطناف بس وش تدافع لك انك تهتم باليهود
يعني غريب بالاهتمام يعني وانت تقول انك
بديت الاهتمام باليهوديه من من قبل
الدراسه يعني قبل التخصص
احنا بدينا نصوره بدايه تصويره ولا
انا في الحقيقه صورت منذ
بديت الاهتمام بالدراسه في تونس في في
ولدت في حي
كان معروف انه فيه كثير من اليهود
المنطقه هذه في تونسيه تسمى منطقه اريانا
وكانت معروفه
بجاليتها اليهوديه
وحتى انه كان في مثل تونسي ويردده يهود
المنطقه هذه يقول له انه اريانا فيها بحر
ما يمشي الانسان القبر
يحبون هذه المدينه فعاشرتهم وانا صغير ثم
حديث عن
والدتي هي كانت من مدينه اريانا فنشا في
هذا الفضول في الحقيقه بدا الفضول في
البدايه
ولكن هذا الفضول الذي كان يعني بدائيا في
الاصل
بدا يتغير مع دخول المعهد الثانوي
والدي كان زيتوني متخرج من جامعه الزيتونه
وكان مهتم كثير بقضايا الشرق الاوسط
في فتره معينه كان ناصري الهواء ككل ابناء
جيلو
اول ثقافه السياسيه في كل ما يتعلق بالشرق
الاوسط
وعندما دخلت الجامعه بدا هذا الاهتمام
يتركز في الحقيقه بدانا ندرس في دار
الاساتذه العليا بدانا نهتم
بقضاء العالم الاسلامي وقضايا العالم
العربي وقضيه الدين الى غير ذلك وبدا هذا
الفضول يت يعني يتغير شيئا فشيئا الى فضول
معرفي
واصبحت عوض ان يكون متلقي اصبحت يعني انا
من اقود هذه الرغبه
وتجذيب وتهذيبها
كتبت اولى مقالتي حول الصراع العربي
الاسرائيلي وانا مازلت في المرحله
الثانويه ثم بعد ذلك يعني في الجامعه بدا
هذا الاهتمام يعني كانوا يعرفون هذا
وكانوا يتنادرون بهذا
الصديق اللي عندهم يهتم بهذا الجانب
اليهودي حتى انه يتخيلون اسما يعني اسما
يهوديا من باب المداعبه
وعندما نجحت في التعليم الثانوي في
البكالوريا توجهت الى التعليم المراحل
الجامعيه
لمناظره التبريد ثم
بعد نجاحي في منظمه الدليل انتقلت الى
باريس
يعني بدات ادرس اللغه العبريه
العبريه الحديثه في
المعهد اللغات الشرقيه في باريس وكنت في
نفس الوقت اتلقى تكوين في المعهد
الكاثوليكي في باريس لانه احتاج الى اللغه
العبريه القديمه واللغات اخرى لم تكن
متيسره في المعهد اللغات الشرقيه كما
السريانيه
والاراميه استكمالا
للدكتوراه
متطلبات البحث الجامعي الذي كان حول
العلاقات الاسلاميه اليهوديه في القروض
الوسطى والجدل الاسلامي اليهودي وبدات هذه
المسيره شيئا فشيئا عدت الى تونس
ولما عدت الى تونس في الحقيقه
كان هاجسي الاول هو ان كانت عندي امكانيه
اني ابقى في باريس
وفي الحقيقه عدت في الاسبوع الذي تحصلت
فيه على وظيفه
لسبب
الاول هو تعلقي بوالدي بكيفيه
يعني لا تتصور انا ابن البكر
وكنت اخاف ان
والدي في
ان يسير بها العمر ولا يجدني الى جنب
وكانت وحتى اني في السكن كنت نسكن الى
جانب والدي يعني بيناتنا بضعه امتار
والسبب الثاني هو انني كنت سالت نفسي
السؤال التالي ما الذي يمكن ان اضيفه الى
الفرنسيه
ففرنسا عندها تقاليد فيما يتعلق باللغه
العبريه والدراسات اليهوديه تمتد الى قرون
ولها من الاخصائيين ما شاء الله
اذا من هو المحتاج
الي هو بلدي
فعدت الى تونس وكانت رغبتي الاولى الاولى
هي المؤسس مركز للدراسات اليهوديه في تونس
مركز بحثي يعني لاحظت بالتجربه اني قمت في
الواقع عندما عدت بدات في التدريس
المساقات بسيطه في اليهوديه في الجامعه
الزيتونيه اللي درست في الجامعه الجامعه
الزيتونيه وكنت مسائل تعلق بالدين ودرست
طلب في قسم التاريخ للامور هناك مسائل على
علاقه بالتاريخ وايضا في قضايا لغويه لان
اللغه العبريه واللغه العربيه قريبتان
وكنت اشعر بمدى حاجه الطلبه الى الى
المصادر
يعني
عندما يريد ان يدخل هذا الميدان لا يجد
نصوص ذات قيمه وذات جوده
في الدراسات اليهوديه
سيجد ساتحدث وما بعد قليل عن نوع النصوص
التي هي تمثل غذاء المواطن العربي ولكن
بالنسبه للطالب الجامعي تقريبا لا شيء او
اشياء نادره وتعد على الاصابع
فبدات افكر في انشاء مركز الدراسات
اليهوديه
ولم تكن للحياه السياسيه
او المناخ السياسي في العالم العربي يسمح
بهذا كنت اعرف
عندما فكرت بيني وبين نفسي اني قلت انه
الافضل ان لا يسمى مركز الدراسات اليهوديه
لنسميه مركز للدراسات الساميه
ممتاز ولم تكن له غايه الغايته الاساسيه
الوحيده هي تكوين مكتبه
يعني كنت افكر وكان مطلبي الاساسي هو كيف
استطيع ان اكون مكتبه علميه فيها افضل ما
ينتج في العالم
سنتعلق الامر في امريكا في فرنسا في
اوروبا في الصين في اسرائيل في اي مكان
ولكن لتكوين طلبتنا في المستقبل
والامر الثاني هو الشروع في الترجمه
تعليم اللغه والشروع في الترجمه لانه
لا نعرف شيئا تقريبا عن اليهوديه ولا عن
اسرائيل
الا نصوص قليله سابين ما هي بالضبط
يعني طالب العربي او طالب التونسي عندما
يريد ان يتخصص في المسائل الدينيه لا يوجد
اي نص عربي نص يهودي مترجم الى اللغه
العربيه
لا وجود التلمود مثلا بالعربيه بالعربيه
ساحدثك عن الطبعات التي ظهرت في السنوات
الاخيره في تلك الوقت لا وجود لترجمه
عربيه
هذا الوقت كان متى في تقريبا 94 95 سنه
بالعربيه لا يوجد تلمود بالعربيه
ظهر بعد ذلك ظهرت نسخه ظهرت نسخه اردنيه
هذه النسخه الاردنيه فيها مشاكل كثيره
يعرفها المتخصصون وهي لا تترجم في الحقيقه
العنوان المظلل لانه لا تترجم كل التلمود
يترجم جزء اسمه المشنه من التلمود
وظهرت بعد ذلك ترجمه مصريه لاجزاء من
المشنه ولكن على كل حال تلمود
صفحه صفحه في الحقيقه هي مزيج من النصوص
مختلفه في الزمن الى غير ذلك وتطلب مجهود
مؤسساتي
اذا هذا بالنسبه للتوراه مثلا لا توجد
ترجمه عربيه للتوراه قام بها مسلمون
الى الان من قام بها الى الان عندنا
ترجمات التي نعرفها متداوله في الحقيقه هي
ترجمات قامت بها الاوساط التبشيريه في
القانون التاسع عشر
مثلا بالنسبه العربيه في الترجمه اللي هي
معتمده في كثير من الاوساط هي الترجمه
اللي قام بها للمستشرق الهولندي فان دايك
موجوده بكثره في الخصوص الفتره
الكاثوليكيه
عندنا ترجمه اخرى موجوده في مصر وفي
الكنائس القبطيه
اللي هي تعود الى التقاليد
الكنيسه الارثوذكسيه
ولكن ان يقوم عربي مسلم بترجمه التوراه
فهذا لم يحدث الى حد اليوم
اقدم ترجمه عربيه للتوراه
مكتمله يعني للاسفار الخمسه هي جزء من
التورات هي قام بها
كان من كبار الاحبار في مصر وكان راس
اكاديميه في العراق
والمسمى بسعديه في القرن الثالث للهجره
بحيث هذا هذا عينه مثلا بيفرق له الترجمه
العربي مسلم طبعا يفرق في في مسائل في
مسائل دينيه
وعقائديه يحتاج الامر الى ان يقرا هذا
الكتاب او يترجم بكيفيه مثلا نعطيك مثلا
النصوص العربيه تتحدث عندما تتحدث عن
الاله تقول الرب
في النصوص هي نصوص مسيحيه مفهوم الاله هو
الرب وادنا الوهم هذه كلها امور تختلف
فيها فيها اختلافات مفهوم الرب في الاوساط
المسيحيه والتقاليد المسيحيه غير المعنى
اليهودي وغير المعنى العربي وقس على ذلك
في اماكن كثيره حتى ان الترجمه العربيه
العبريه للقران من احدى المشاكل التي
يعني اثيرت هو انه بعض الترجمات تتعلق
ببيت المقدس ترجمت بكيفيه خاطئه ترجمت
لهيكل مثلا
على كل حال هناك امر يعرفه المحصلون لهذه
الامور
في فراغ نعطيك مثال انه عندما تقول
اليهوديه لا يمكن ان تقول اليهوديه بدون
ان تشير الى الرب مشيب ميمون الرب موسى بن
ميمون القرطبي
هذا الرجل هو يعني عمده اليهود في القرون
الوسطى في كل يوم في كل ما يتعلق بالفقه
والتفسير الى غير ذلك
وعرفه العرب من خلال حديثا من خلال كتاب
دلاله الحائرين
حققه تركي حسين التاي
وروشر بعد ذلك في مصر بطباعات مسروق
المهم هذا الرجل يسمى عند اليهود بنسر
الكنيسه
يعني حتى حتى المستشفيات في اسرائيل تسمى
باسمه واليهود يقولوا
من موسى النبي الى موسى هذا لم يظهر في
اليهود موسى مثله مثل هذا مثل هذا الرجل
نصوص مشن ترى مثلا
نصوص الفقه الكبير غير مترجمه الى العربي
لا يعرفها العرب السنوات الاخيره ظهر كتيب
صغير ولكن مختصر للمشني ترى
بحيث هذا غيظ منفيض نتحدث عن الادب ونتحدث
على الشعر ونتحدث على كل سواء عن التفسير
فهناك فقر متقه في العالم العربي
اللي عنده اسباب تاريخيه بطبيعه الحال
ولكن من العبث ان يتواصل
[موسيقى]
طور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
بس وش اهميه فهم العربي باليهود
طبعا يعني اجيبك بطريقتي الطريقه الاولى
هو انه هو استئناف لتقاليد اجدادنا
يعني الاهتمام بالاخر
وبديانه الاخرين قديم في ثقافتنا قدمنا
افضل النصوص في القرون الوسطى قدمنا نصوص
الشهر الثاني فالملل والنحل قدمنا نصوص
ابن حزم الاندلسي فالفصل في الملل
والاهواء والنحل قدمنا نصوص البيروني في
التحقيق ملء الهند
فهؤلاء العلماء
قدموا في زمنهم معارف متقدمه بكثره وساهمت
في فهم بطبيعه الحال العرب والمسلمين
للديانات الاخرى لانه جزء جزء من هذه
الديانات نحن مطالبون بمعرفته في الحصول
القديمه يعني كل ما يتعلق بالذمه مثلا
واحكام اهل الذمه
يجب ان يكون هناك معرفه بهؤلاء بسيط
احد الخلفاء العباسيين عندما عاد من
العراق جاء من العراق في الحج اعترضته
طائفه من الطوائف كانت تغتسل في نهر دجله
والفرات
فسال عنهم من انتم من اي اي ديانه تتبعون
فلم يتلقى اجابه واضحه
وكان يتحدث وكان المقصود بذلك هو طائفه
الصابئه
ولا تذكرون في القران
والمسلمون تحرجوا كثيرا في تصنيف هؤلاء
منهم الكتاب ام لا
فاذا كانوا اهل الكتاب فعندم احكام معينه
واذا كانوا غير من غير ذلك
فالمهم انه هؤلاء الصابئه اختلف المسلمون
في معرفتهم ووقعنا في شيء مظلل في الحقيقه
يعود الى صاحب الى النديم في الفهريست
لانه خلط بين نوعين من الصبي صابئه اليوم
ذكرهم القران وهم ينتمون الى الطائفه من
المسيوديين سنتحدث عنهم
صبيئه صبيئه البطائح
وهم معروفون للسيد المسيح
وهناك اصابيه حران
الذين يعبدون الكواكب والنجوم وهم وثنيون
وادى هذا الى خلط كبير في تصورات الفقهاء
في كيفيه التعامل مع هؤلاء خصوصا هذا
الامبراطوريه الاسلاميه عندما تمددت
كان عليها ان ان تتعامل مع اقليات دينيه
وعرقيه ولغويه
واستطاعت الحضاره الاسلاميه ان تعالج هذا
الملف الى فتره معينه بطبيعه الحال الى
حدود انتهاء الدوله العثمانيه ضمن نظام
الذمه وضمن نظام المليات في الدوله
العثمانيه اللي هو قائم على الفقه الحنفي
فاذا هذا هناك مطلب
معرفي يجب ان نعرف هؤلاء الاخرين واستمرار
لتقاليد ارساها اجدادنا
ولكن
هذه المعارف التي افساها اجدادنا ستتوقف
في جزء كبير من صلاحيتها مع انهيار
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه ميلاد العالم
الحديث
واحدى العيوب التي نعاني منها اليوم في
معرفه الديانات الاخرى هو اننا نكرر ما
قاله الاجداد في القرون الوسط
وهذا امر فيه كثير من العيوب التي يجب ان
يتخلى عنها المسلمون والعرب بفهم بطبيعه
الحال هذا العالم الحديث وان شئتنا التوسع
في الحديث في هذا بطبيعه الحال كيف يجب ان
نعرف هؤلاء الاخرين ليس من منطق لانه
العصر العصور القديمه كانت تنظر في هذه
الديانات منطلق امرين منطلق اول هو الدفاع
عن العقائد الايمانيه كما يقول ابن خلدون
والدفاع عن الاسلام
لبيان افضليه الاسلام على الديانه الاخرى
هذا يسمى
او الدفاع ولكن الوجه الثاني هو يعني
الجدل
هناك ثنائيه تتحكم في القرون الوسطى هي
ثنائيه الدفاع والجدل وبطبيعه الحال
العالم الحديث
او دراسه الاديان في العالم الحديث تخلت
عن هذين المبدئين لانهما مبدا لا يتوافقان
مع شروط العلم المعاصر فيما يتعلق
بالدراسات الدينيه وعلى المسلمين ان ينظر
الى الدينات يبدو خطابا وكلاما في
الديانات الاخرى يستجيب لنا التحول الذي
عرفته وعرفه العالم منذ القرن 18
على وجه الخصوص طب هل فهم العرب
والدراسات العرب للمسيحيه برضو توقفت ولا
بس توقفت مقابل اليهود
لا هو هو الامر نتحدث عن الجانب العربي
المسلم صح انه في عرب مسيحيين
بالنسبه للجانب العربي المسلم توقف الامر
مع كل الديانه يعني عمليه الانحطاط لعرفها
العالم العربي انحطاط شامل
يعني لم يستثني المسيحيين واهتم واهتم
باليهود امر يعني امر امر شالم ومثل ما
هناك خطاب ضعيف في الجانب الاسلامي فيما
يتعلق بالديانات الكتاب يعني اليهوديه
والمسيحيه هناك جهل اكبر ومطبق ومطلق
انشاء بالديانات الاسيويه وديانات الهند
وديانه امريكا اللاتينيه الى غير ذلك يعني
هذا الامر يحتاج الى ان الى ان يتغير
فردت من خلال تاسيس هذا المركز على الاقل
هو ان اقوم
بتحسيس بسد هذا الفراغ الذي طال
انا مذكر دائما وابدا كنت دائما نص ابن
حزم الاندلسي في كتاب الرد على ابن غريبه
اليهودي يقول اللهم اليك اشكو تشاهد اهل
الممالك
بعباره قصور يتركون عما قريب وبجمع اموال
ربما كانت عونا لاعداء عليهم عن حيازه
ملتهم التي بها عز الى غير ذلك حتى استطال
اهل الذمه وكذا وكذا فهذا ينادينا من وراء
القرون
اشتغلوا بهذه المساء
فعندما بدات اذا البحث في تاسيس هذا
المركز لوظيفتين تكوين مكتبه وتاسيس
مترجمين وسدا لهذا الفرع
كان علي ان احل مشكله سياسيه لمن ساتوجه
القرار السياسي ليس بيدي ولا بيد
وكنت نبهت منذ 92 فيما قال شهير في احدى
الجرائع التونسيه طلبت طلبت بتاسيس
لتدريس الاديان
ساعود الى المركز الذي حدثنا ولكن هذا
المقال وتسعين نبهت
الدوله التونسيه قد عرفت انتقال السلطه من
الحبيب بورقيبه زعيم الحبيب بورقيبه الى
الى زين العابدين بن علي وكان هناك مشكله
دينيه وهذه المشكله دينيه
في الحقيقه هي تعترض تونس كل 20 سنه بسبب
المشكله الدينيه التي لم تحل
تونس عرفت ازمات دوريه وستعرف المستقبل
الدوليه كل عشرين سنه تقريبا
والسب هو المشكله الدينيه فطلبت في هذا
المقال مثل ما تفكر الدوله طلبت بالقائمين
انتم تفكرون في انشاء مهندسين جيدين
وتفكرون في انشاء اطباء جيدين في انشاء
رجال اعمال جيدين فكروا في انشاء مؤسسات
دينيه جيده تشتغل وفق شروط العلم المعاصر
لان عليه ان يخلق مؤسسات دينيه
تتناسب مع النظام الجمهوري مثل ما فعلت
فرنسا او غير فرنسا في فرنسا موجوده
المعهد الكاثوليكي مثلا استمر ولكن فرنسا
نظام جمهوري خلق
مؤسسات الشعب الخامسه والشعب الرابعه في
المسائل الدينيه واللغويه الساميه
لكي تجد هذه الانظمه الجمهوريه مؤسسات
دينيه تستطيع ان تكون سندها زمن الازمات
على كل حال
في تلك الفتره
وكفتي كثير من الدول حتى المجاوره لنا كان
الامر يعتبر ان هذه المساله الدينيه هي
مساله امنيه ويجب ان تحل بالوسائل الامنيه
ولكن الناس شيء
وهو ان المسائل الامنيه تستطيع ان توقف
الارهاب توقف العنف المادي
[موسيقى]
عندما بحثت عن شخص اشار علي باحد
المسؤولين الذي اشتغل في فتره معينه منذ
زمن بورقيبه في
المنتظم الاممي قلت هذه الشخصيه اعتباريه
وتساعدني وطلبت منه ان يكون هو رئيس
المركز ورئيس
ان اكون اي منصب مهم ان يتحقق هذا المشروع
وكنت اتصور ان هذا ضمانه في الحقيقه
ولكن بعد بعد خروجه من اللقاء صدر في احدى
الجرائد بعد يوم او يومين
خبر صغير
علمنا ان احد الاساتذه التونسيين يفكر في
انشاء مركز الدراسات اليهوديه في اطار
التطبيع
ففهمت انه
مغزى هذه الرساله
فمزقت كل الملف وكل الاوراق وتخليت منذ
تلك الفتره عن هذا المشروع
واكتفيت بالتدريس الجامعي
ومنذ تلك الفتره يعني اهتممت بتكوين طلبتي
في حدود معينه وسعيد داخل الجامعه التي
تدرس فيها الى انشاء او الى الى ثل من
الاصدقاء في تاسيس قسم للاديان
بما فيها اليهوديه والمسيحيه الى غير ذلك
لعل الزمن يتكفل بعد ذلك بتحقيق ما عجزت
عنه في في تلك الفتره والذي انا عاجز عنه
الى اليوم بطبيعه الحال لان الامور لم تسر
بل وتيره التي تصورت
وشغلتني الحياه اليوميه عن كثير من
المشاغل العلم والى اخره فالحقيقه نحن
نعمل في ظروف صعبه
صحيح نحن اساتذه الجامعيون ولكن الظروف
التي تشتغل فيها لا تسمح لتحقيق كل ما
نريد لان الان يعني اقتربت من سن تقاعد
ولا اعتقد انني حققت اكثر من ثلاثه في
المئه او اربعه في المئه مما كنت اتصور او
استطيع ان احققه لو توفرت توفرت ظروف اخرى
ومناخ اخر واراده اخرى وامكانيات اخرى
ولذلك توجهت منذ سنوات اذا الى الى الى
العالم الافتراضي مثل هذا وغيره لعل هذا
الصوت يخرج من الحيطان الدرس الى العالم
العربي الى الدول الاخرى تستطيع ان تفهم
الحاجه ليست حاجه تونس وانما حاجه العالم
العربي والحاجه العالمي الى ان يهتم بمثل
هذه المسائل وفقا بطبيعه الحال مقاربه
جديده لان يعتقد ان استقرار العالم العربي
الاجتماعي والسياسي في المستقبل السنوات
القادمه مرهون بمعالجه ما سميه بالمشكله
الدينيه
لهذا هذا هذا كتبت في هذا كثير وقمت
بمحاضرات في هذا وهذه قناعتي يعني العالم
العربي بكل دوله ليس بمنجا من الهزات في
المستقبل ما لم تحل هذه المساله الدينيه
التي عجز العالم العربي عن حاليا منذ 100
سنه
اضعنا ثوره اضعنا الثوره الصناعيه واضعنا
الثوره الرقميه وربما الان سنضيع ثوره
الذكاء الاصطناعي لاننا ما زلنا نراوح
مكاننا في نفس النقطه التي بدانا منها وهي
كيف نعيد ترتيب علاقتنا مع الدين لا يقول
لا اقول مناهضه الدين
حتى لا افهم خطا الدين موجود وجد ويوجد
وسيوجد في المستقبل ولكن اعاده ترتيب
العلاقه مع الدين هي التي يحتاج العالم
العربي الى ان يوليها الاهميه القصوى ما
اراه مع الاسف
هو الاختصار على الجوانب الظاهره في
المسائل الدينيه الظواهر العنف او ظواهر
ولكن الامور اعمق بكثير من العنف مثل
طريقه تفكير كيف كيف ينظر المواطن العربي
الى المساله الدينيه اذا كانت مساله فرديه
فهي تتعلق بالاخلاق
بطريقه الحياه في المجتمع الى غيره ولكن
عندما التحول هذه الدين الى مساله جماعيه
هو في قلب السياسه
ولهذا هذا الموضوع سيكون موجود في
المستقبل
وبشده وعلى الذي يهتم بهذه المسائل ان
ينظر الى ضروره تاسيس انا على الاقل في
جانب الاكاديمي يجب ان تتاسس في العالم
العربي جامعه ومؤسسات تشتغل في هذا
الموضوع
وفق شروط العلم العلم المعاصر في المسائل
الدينيه وان تقدم بطبيعه حال المشوره
والراي وتنتج والد وتغير فيه في طريقه
ادراك الانسان العربي للمسائل الدينيه لكل
الديانات وليس فقط وانا اخترت بحكم
اهتماماتي منذ الطفوله هذا المجال مجال
الدراسات اليهوديه الذي ازعم او ارى انني
استطيع ان اتحدث فيه في الحقيقه بكيفيه
تعالج اهم اهم نقاط ضعف في هذا الموضوع
هذا طيب فيها نقطه تقول انت ان المواطن
العربي اليوم
في فهمه لليهوديه ضحيه لعدد من الاخطاء
وتقول ان في الستينات
ساهمت السياسه في تجهيل المواطن العربي
باليهوديه يعرف ما هي الاخطاء
وكيف ساهمت السياسه في تجهيل المواطن
العربي
في اخطاء لانه
الخطا الاول والواضح هو اننا نقتات
من تراث قديم يعني المواطن العربي عندما
يريد ان يفهم ماذا سيجد قبل كل شيء سيذهب
الى معرض الكتاب سيشتري كتاب ابن حزم
او كتاب كتاب البيروني في اجزاء منه يتحدث
عن اليهوديه او الشهر الثاني او غيرها من
النصوص
وهذه فيها مشاكل كبيره ساتحدث عن حدودها
بطبيعه الحال
كما قلت تحكم فيها اليتيتي الجدل والدفاع
المشكله الثاني
اذهب الى اي مكان في اي سوق عربيه وحاول
ان تجد كتب في اليهوديه ما عدا ثلاث او
اربعه او عشره عناوين مهمه
البقيه ستجد ان غذاء المواطن العربي يتمثل
في ثلاثه واربعه كتب ساعطيك بعض عناوينها
مثلا
سيجد بروتوكولات حكماء صهيون هذا الكتاب
بس سيلر يعني هو كتاب يعني وصل في طبعاته
العربيه الى ارقام خياليه
ترجمه خليفه التونسي
تجد كتاب اخر مثلا وهو بالغ الشهره كتاب
اسمه او باسماء مختلفه فطير صهيون
تجد كتاب اخر مثلا الكنز المرصود في قواعد
التلمود ولا علاقه لهذا الكتاب بالتلمود
على ذلك من الكتب
هذه الكتب وكنت اجد في تونس فتره معينه
طويله في الحقيقه على قارئ عن طريق كتب
مثلا كفاحي
فهذه الكتب ما هي المعارف التي تقدمها
للمواطن العربي
لا شيء
اولا هذه كتب
تنشر شيئا اسمه معاداه السميه
وساوضح لك بالضبط فيها
كتاب فطير صهيون
يتحدث عن بلاد ليبل
يعني تهمه الدم
شيء نشره شخص اسمه الكيلاني وحتى انه احد
وزراء الدفاع في سوريا مشهور اللواء مصطفى
طلاس
كتب كتابا في هذا واراد ان يقدموا اطروحه
هذا الكتاب مثلا بالذات ساتحدث عن الكل
بقيه الكتب
كتاب فطير الدم هو يتحدث عن تهمه تقول انه
اليهود في عيد الفصح
يحتاجون الى الدم
ليخلطوه بالعجين ليصنعوا فطير عيد الفصح
وهذه تهمه مسيحيه
من تهم القروض الوسطى
التي ساهمت في العداء المسيحي اليهودي لان
العداء المسيحي مع اليهود مع اليهودي هو
عداء عقائدي بالاساس وهو ليس تماما ليس
مثل الخلاف الموجود بين الاسلام واليهوديه
وسابين الخلاف عقائدي
لان اليهود يعتبرون ان اليهود هم
المسيحيين يعتبرون ان اليهود هم الذين
قتلوا المسيح
وان يهود الاسخريوتي هو الذي باعه الى بعد
العشاء الاخير الى السلطات الرومانيه وتم
دن صلبه الى غير ذلك
وانهم قتلا الى اخره وهناك على كل حال
عداء عقائدي استمر الى الى الى العصر
الحديث هذه احدى مظاهر
اليهود مثل ما قتلوا المسيح اذا هم يقومون
بهذه الخلطه من العجينه
نعرفها في تاريخنا هل سمعت في تاريخنا
بشيء اسمه مثل هذا يعني نعطيك مثال
الحادثه الوحيده في تاريخنا تقول ان ان
اليهود اتهموا بقتل الرسول
في حديث الشاه المسموم
وان الرجل الصحابي الذي اكل مع النبي في
حادثه الشتاء المسمومه هو البراء بن معروف
وهو الوحيد الذي لم يشاء ان يغير القبله
بالمناسبه البراء ابن معرور اكل وتوفي
بسبب
وان المسلمين لا يرون ان رسول الله مات
شهيدا مع ما اكرمه الله به من النبوه
يا اخي تصور لو ان المسلمين صاروا في هذا
الاتجاه وقالوا ان اليهود قتلوا
قتلوا النبي مثلما قتل اليهود
المسيح ونحن نعرف ان اجدادنا لم يسيروا في
هذا الاتجاه ان الخلاف حول عصمه النبي
استمر الى القرن القرن السابع نجد باقيه
في كتاب الفخر الدين الرازي في مفاتيح
الغيب
يقول انتهاء المسلمون الى فكره التاليه
وهو ان الرسول
معصوب فيما يبلغه عن ربه فقط في ذاكرته
ولكنه في بدنه يصيبه ما يصيب كل الناس
كسرت رباعيته وجرح في غيبا الى اخره ويمرض
ويصحى ربما
اليهود الى غير ذلك وانكر المعتز لذلك على
كل حال لم يذهب المسلمون اطلاقا الى ان
الرسول قتل
وبالتالي ليس لنا خلاف مع اليهود من طبيعه
الخلاف
فكاننا بهذا الكتاب الذي
فطير صهيون هذا هذه التهمه متى ظهرت ظهرت
سنه 1830 تقريبا
في دمشق
وبتدخل من القنصل الفرنسي الذي حبك كل هذه
المؤامره
لان فرنسا ستقع ابتداء من 1922 تحت
الانتداب الفرنسي
فكان هذه وهناك مواضيع هناك كتابات على كل
حال تبيت هذا بشكل تفصيلي كاننا ادخلنا
الى الثقافه الاسلاميه تهمه من تهم معادات
الساميه الى حضاره لم تكن معاديه للسمير
الاطلاق
نوضح في مصطلح المتشابهه هناك معاهده
اليهود فهناك معاه
وصار معاهده الساميه كلمه معاداه السميه
صارت وكانها حكر على معادله اليهود لاسباب
تاريخي ان اليهود قاموا بدور دور كبير في
ترسيخ هذه الفكره في الوعي الغربي خصوصا
بعد ما حادثه ما يسمى بالهولوكوست او
المحرقه المحرقه النذير
وتناسى العالم تناسى العالم انه العرب هم
ايضا ساميون
هذا موضوع موضوع معقد وستكون لنا ساتحدث
فيه بما يفيد بما يفيب الغرض قلت اصبح
الان هناك حديث عن لا سميع المعادلات
السميه الاسلاميه
في كتابه جيش
وفي اسلام وغيره نعطيك مثال في في شخص في
امراه
متخصصه في هذا
اسمها
يهوديه مصريه
اسمها الحقيقي جيزال ليتمان
ذهبت الى سويسرا بعد خروجها من مصر وتزوجت
احد كبار المستشرقين اليهود الامريكيين
عندها حديث عما تسميه تسميه اوربيا
ومجموعه كثيره من الكتب التي تتحدث
عن ان هذه المعادات معادات الساميه
عند المسلمين متاصله في التاريخ
[موسيقى]
وان اول معادله للساميه هو الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
وتبعها في ذلك لفيف مثلا في شخص
ايضا في امريكا معروف بهذا
ساتذكر اسمه
هو المسؤول عن ما يسمى بالكمبيس واتش
يعني في امريكا عندهم مرصد اسمه مرصد
الجامعات
وهذا المرصد وظيفته هي متابعه كل الاساتذه
العرب
خصوصا العرب وغير العرب المتعاطفين مع
العرب والقضيه الفلسطينيه
وخصوصا في مراكز دراسات الشرق الاوسط
اي انسان يبحث في كلمه
ازعج كثير واتعب كثير ادوارد سعيد مثلا
وظيفتهم هي تصيد اي كلام في الجامعات
الامريكيه مناهض لليهوديه ومناظ الصهيونيه
او مناظي لاسرائيل
وفي تيار نبهت اليه كثير من الان هو تيار
ما يسمى بالصهيونيه
المسيونيه الجديده كريستيانيتي
سنتحدث عنه بعد قليل عندما
نحت في اللغه العربيه وجدت ترجمه شبيهه
بهذا وانا لم اشاء ان اخلق ترجمه جديده
تجنب لهذه الفوضى ولكن احتفظ بهذا فعندما
اقول مسيهوديه فانا اقسم
ولكن هناك مسيووديه قديمه الاسلام الاول
بها علاقه والمسيونيه الحديثه التي تجمع
اوساط مسيحيه صهيونيه واوساط معاديه للعرب
وللمسلمين وهي مبثوثه في كل العالم الغربي
وفي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتقوم
بدور جبار وعمل جبار في مناهضه القضيه
الفلسطينيه ومنافكه العرب المسلمين
هذا الخطاب الذي يقول ان هؤلاء العرب هم
وعدون السمين وانهم وان هذا الامر متاصل
في تاريخهم
باش نقدم للقارئ او عفوا للمستمع
احدى احدى الخزعبلات والتي يفرح بها
الجهل من العرب مع الاسف
الرسول هو اول معادي للسالميه لانه ذبح
900 يهودي في في قريظه
الحادث المعروف بمجزره بني قريص
تختلف يعتمد مصادر تقول انه 700 او 900
يهود قتلوا ذبحا وان العنف وان القتل وان
الذبح هذا متاصل في مسلمين على ذلك الولبي
وهم هو اول من قدم
نموذجا لهذا الفعل الشنيع وذبح اليهود
ربما استطاع هتلر ان يفعل ذلك للامور
التقنيه تغيرت في عهده ولكن في بمقياس ذلك
الزمان فهذا الامر يعني موجود منذ القديم
ولكن فات هؤلاء
ان هذه الحادثه بالرجوع وتثبت في النصوص
هي من الاحداث التي رواها مهتدون
مهتدون بمعنى يهود اسلموا
فهؤلاء هذه الروايه التي نقلها المهتدون
عندما نبحث من ناحيه التاريخيه ندخل تحت
المجهر التاريخي سنرى ان هؤلاء خلطوا بين
حديثتين
حادثه موجوده في اللاوعي اليهود القديم
وهي حادثه مسد
حادثه مساده هي مجموعه من اليهود الذين في
قلعه في في فلسطين
احتموا بها وحصروا من قبل الرومان
وفضلوا الانتحار والقتل ان يقتلوا انفسهم
بدون ان يسلموا انفسهم
لللفيف الروماني او للجيش الروماني الذي
لا يقهر في ذلك الزمان
وادمجت هذه الحادثه حديثه هذا الانتحار
الجماعي
[موسيقى]
تتحدث عن اليهود بطريقه بطوليه هذا الموت
البطولي الذين كانوا يذهبون الى الموت وهم
يعني يعني النساء يعني
متزينات والرجال اذا يسال عن فلان اين هو
وفلانه فلا خير في حياه بعد وكانوا يذهبون
الى الموت بهذه بهذا الافتخار فهذا في
صدالي لحادثه
وبعض الذين بعض وعدد قليل من الذين قتلوا
في هذه المعركه بمقاييس ذلك زمان في معارك
ذلك الزمان
هذا اولا هذا يجب يحتاج الى امر
وبالمناسبه قلعه مصادر هذه الان هي موجوده
في اسرائيل في فلسطين المحتله وضباط الجيش
الاسرائيلي المتخرجون الاكاديميه العسكريه
بعضهم يتلقى ميشانات نيشين الرتب في هذه
القلعه
ويحلفون في هذه القلعه انه لن يصيب
اسرائيل ما اصاب اجدادهم في مصادر
الامر الثاني المدينه في ذلك الزمان او
يثرب في ذلك الزمان لم تكن مدينه عامره
بمقاييس هذا الوقت لنتصور ان قتل فيها 900
شخص
هذا يخلق من المشاكل الصحيه
والامراض
ما لا يمكن تصوره
ثم اخطر من هذا لو ان هذا الحديث وقع فعلا
نحن نعرف ان سنه النبي هي قوليه وفعليه
وان المسلمين يستنون بصينه النبي ولو ان
هذا الامر وقع على استنى به الفقهاء لا
نجد اثر لهذه الحادثه في كتب الفقهاء وفي
كتب الجهه
كان الامر هذا صحيحا استنى ولا حرص
المسلمون على نقدي ونتعامل مع اليهود طوال
التاريخ الاسلامي بمقتضى هذه ولربما لانه
عاشوا معنا لقرون طويله سيبدو ما يعرفون
من من المسيحيين اقل بكثير مما كان يمكن
ان يعرفوه مع لانه في الدول تاريخنا
المستمعون ان لم يظهر لم يحدث في تاريخ
اليهود في البلاد الاسلاميه الا حديثتين
بسيطتين من
المعادات لليهود الاولى في عهد الحاكم
بامر الله الفاطمي وكان انسانا مريضا وفعل
بالمسلمين اكثر مما فعل باليهود وحرق
القاهره
وطلب من الناس ان يسيروا ليلا وان يناموا
نهارا
واشبه بنيرون يعني
الامر الثاني في عهد الدوله الموحديه
ولم نعرف في تاريخنا من دعى الى قتل
اليهود بهذه الكيفيه
كما عرفت اوروبا في تاريخ البوغرام يعني
في تاريخ
المجازر الدوريه التي عرفتها اوروبا وكان
اخرها مذبحه كيشي ليف في اوروبا في اوروبا
الشرقيه اذا هناك اشياء كثيره تدل على ان
هذه الحادثه التي تضخم فيها الاوساط
الصهيونيه اليوم لبيان ان هناك معاداه
للساميه اسلاميه متاصله
كما قلت ضعاف النفوس من العرب التكوين
ينقلون هذه الاحداث ويرون فيها مصدرا
للافتخار وكانهم بهذه الامور
يعني يقبلون بمعادات الساميه الاسلاميه
ويقبلون
بهذه
الامور وكان في ذلك افتخارا والبعض يذهب
اكثر من هذا الى الافتخار او او على كل
حال الى عدم تكذيب الروايه المحرق النازيه
وهذا امر امر خطير جدا يجب
الغرب ان لا يدخلوا في باب النفي للمحرق
النازيه هذا امر نبه اليه لتوارد سعيد
كبار الاذكياء في العالم العربي في مؤتمر
في بيروت
وقبولنا وتعاطفنا مع المحرقه مع اليهود
وغير اليهود من
المحرق لم تصب فقط اليهود لانه هذا المدخل
الحقيقي لان يعترف العالم لنا بالنكبه
العربيه لان النكبه هي محرقه
العرب والفلسطينيين في العصر الحديث وهذا
وهذا بينه بكل التوفيق الدكتور جلباب اشقر
في كتابه عن عن النكبه وعلى كل حال اشياء
كثيره في تاريخنا تحتاج الى ان تراجع وان
يكتب فيها المتخصصون وان ينير العقول في
العالم العربي حتى لا يسير وفق هذا
المنهج العاطفي الذي يؤدي الى كوارث والى
امور عكسيه في في ردود افعالنا اعطيك مثال
هناك كثير من العرب
ممن قام بحمايه
اليهود من العسف الناس في تونس وفي
الجزائر وفي المغرب وفي مصر وفي غيره
وهؤلاء لا يعرف لا يعرف عنهم العرب شيئا
اليهود يعرفون عنهم في اسرائيل هناك في
فتحه في المحرقه اسماء لبعض هؤلاء لانه من
الناحيه الفقهيه اليهوديه
يعتبرون انهم امه على صوابهم الى الدين
الحقيقي ولكن هناك يحدث في بعض الشعوب
الاخرى ان يكون هناك بعض الاخيار وهذا
يسمى في الفقه اليهودي حسيدي موت علام
يعني اخيار او اتقياء امم العالم وفيها
تونسيون ومغاربه وغيرهم فالاولى اذن لان
نعلم ابنائنا ان عدائنا لم يهود لم يكن
عندا عقائديا الكتاب الثاني هذا
للاخر
للكنز المرصود في قواعد التلمود هذا كتبه
طبيب نازي
ولا علاقه له عندما تقرا هذا الكتاب لا
علاقه له لا بالتلمود ولا بشروحه وانما هو
في الادب المسيحي المعادي للتلمود الذي
في تاريخيا المسيحيه او الاوساط المسيحيه
حرقت التلمود ومنعت التونود الى غير
رغم ان التلمود في طبعته الحاليه ظهر على
يد مسيحي في القرن الخامس عشر يعني بدايه
عصر النهضه في
الكتاب الاخر هو بروتوكولات وتبين على كل
حال ان هذا الكتاب وهذا امر معروف عند
المتخصصين انه من عمل المخابرات القيصريه
ولا اتحدث عن كفاحي
فعندما نقدم هذا النوع من الثقافه للمواطن
العربي هل ساعدناه على ان يفهم اليهوديه
هل ساعدنا على ان يفهم اسرائيل ان يفهم
ردود فعل اسرائيل لا ابدا
وفستينات اقول في الستينات
الصراع العسكري مع مع اسرائيل لم يكن
دافعا
للانظمه على ان تهتم بتاسيس مراكز
الدراسات اليهوديه
وتكوين الخبراء والى غير ذلك متى بدات هذه
الصدمه بدات بعد هزيمه 67
يعني تذكر بعض وزراء الحربيه والمخابرات
المصريه انه عبد الناصر بعد 67 بدا يذهب
الى المقر المخابرات المصريه ليرى وجوه
هذه الجدريلات
الاسرائيليين وبدات حركه للترجمه في
الجامعه العربيه
وبدا تقسم اللغه العبريه تشتغل شيئا فشيئا
وبدات هناك محاوله لبناء معرفه علميه
المشكله انه جزء كبير من هؤلاء الذين تم
تكوينهم في تلك المرحله وكان للمصريين دور
وكان العراقيين دور وكان السوريين دور انه
اغلبهم توجه الى العمل الامني والعمل
المخابرات لم تربح منه الحياه الجامعيه
والاكاديميه الشيء الكثير
اضافه الى ان هذه الاقسام طل ظل ينظر
اليها على اساس انها طابور خامس
يعني من حيث رؤيه المجتمع عليها ظلت عليها
مش المؤسسه الجامعيه يعني
رحمه الله وفي قلبه غصه لانه لم يتمكن من
انشاء المركز الذي يريد في الدراسات
اليهوديه
والاسرائيليه على كل حال في العالم العربي
لا توجد الا ثلاث مراكز
يعني الان الصراع بدا من قبل 48 الى اليوم
لا توجد الا ثلاث مراكب في المركز اضمحل
هو مركز الابحاث الفلسطيني اللي كان في
بيروت وكان
في علاقه متوتره مع الرئيس عرفات فتره
طويله
وعند اجتياح بيروت قام اريال شارون بنهب
كل المحتويات التي موجوده وحملها الى
اسرائيل والبعض ما بقي حمل الى الجزائر
وفي احدى المخازن وانتهت تجربه مركز
الابحاث
الذي قدم لنا افضل المتخصصين في الشان
اليهودي وفشان الاسرائيلي ومازال بعضهم
يعني الى اليوم يعني منارات في هذا في هذا
المجال اذا ما الذي بقي بقي عنا مركز مدار
في رمل وهو مؤسسه بحثيه خاصه ومركز
الزيتونه في غزه
ومركز الدراسات الفلسطينيه اللي هو بين
بيروت والولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا كل
معنى
فقط شيئا ما في مركز الدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في الاهرامين جزء من
اهتمامات ولكن
هذا لا يرقى انا عندي احصائيات قديمه
وذكرتها في اكثر من مره في التسعينات كان
في اسرائيل حوالي 35 ماركت للدراسات
العربيه الاسلاميه يهتم من المغرب الى
تشقن
وبعضهم تابعه لوزاره الخارجيه على
الجامعات قمت بدراسه حول الدراسات العربيه
الاسلاميه مثلا في الجامعات الثمانيه
الاسرائيليه
والشيخ تابعه وزاره الدفاع او وزاره
الجيش يعني وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه والخارجيه الى
فما بالك اليوم
يعني هناك عدم تناسب مطلق
بين بين
ما تقوم باسرائيل لفهم العالم العربي لا
احدثك عن الدراسات الاسلاميه
هذا امر
لو حدثتك عنه لبقيت يعني مندهشه
الان افضل الدراسات فيما يتعلق بالاسلام
عندما اقول افضل الدراسات يعني يعني التي
تريد ان هي الدراسات متخصصه في في العالم
العربي في التاريخ في الادب الى اخره في
الدين ايضا
وانا الان بصدد ترجمه كتاب
لاسرائيلي حول حول حول المدينه مدينه
النبي حول يثرب عندهم دراسات كثيره في هذا
الموضوع
يعني يا اخي
افضل افضل الانتاج هو يتم في بريستون
الامريكيه اكسفورد البريطانيه والجامعه
العبريه في القدس هذه الجامعه التي تاسست
قبل قيام اسرائيل سنه 1925 المشروع
الاكاديمي تاسس قبل قيام الدوله
وفي مجلات كثيره يعني اما جي اس يعني
البريطانيه
في اسرائيل وكنت اكتب تقريبا في احدى
الجرائد العمانيه متابعه شهريه لكل ما
ينتج في اسرائيل على العالم العربي
فعندما اقارن هذا بذلك اجد ان ان ان
الامر لا يستقي مع توفر الدواعى
الامنيه والعلميه والسياسيه والاقتصادي
مع وجود الاموال ووجود الرجال
فكان دعوه
ابن حزم الاندلسي الى اليوم لم تجد صدر
هذا هو الذي يجعلني في هذه السن اشعر
بالاحباط
لانني اعرف ما الذي سيحدث في المستقبل
هذا التقصير الذي طال سيؤدي الى وخيم
العواقب وخيمه العواقب السياسيه او
العسكريه
اولا والدينيه وافضل مثال ما ترونه ما
ترونه اليوم من هذه الموجه الطبيعيه في
العالم العربي
التي قد تكون لها ربما مبررات سياسيه
ولكنها غافله من الناحيه الدينيه ومن
الناحيه الثقافيه ومن الناحيه الاكاديميه
هي لا تعرف بالضبط جوهر هذه هي المشروع
الصهيوني الذي بدا منذ جذور هيرزل الى
اليوم وصولا الى الاتفاقيات الابراهيميه
التي تحدثت عن خطرها في المسائل الدينيه
وخطرها الماكر في الحقيقه التي سيؤدي الى
وخيمه الى وخيم العوائق
نتكلم عنه
الموضوع الان احنا تكلمنا عن بعض الاشياء
وبعض السياقات لفهمنا ولحالنا اليوم
ادخل في فهم اليهود بس قبلها ان كنت تقول
في وحده من اقتباسات انه
انه نحن امام شعب دون تاريخه بنفسه
ويجي في بالي انه كل الشعوب دون تاريخه
بنفسها
ليش ذكرت انهم هم دون طريقه بنفسه لا
سابين لك صحيح وسؤال معقول ولكن ما اردت
البيان وهو هو فويرق صغير
عندما تفتدي تفتح دائره المعارف الاسلاميه
هي دائره موسوعه التاريخ الاسلامي
ثقافه الاسلاميه العربي الاسلامي من يكتب
فيها
كل شعوب العالم
اجد فيها الصيني والفرنسي والالماني
والانجليزي والتونسي
والهند الى غير ذلك
افتح دائره المعارف الاسلاميه اليهوديه لن
تجد فيها الا اليهود
لن تجد فيها شخصا اخر غير يهودي
هذا يعني نموذج بسيط في العصر الحديث ولكن
انا اتحدث عن التوراه في الحقيقه هذا
الحديث حديث عن الثورات
يعني
تقديم تاريخ اسرائيل القديمه او ما يسمى
ببني اسرائيل حتى نخلط بين الاسرائيليين
وبني اسرائيل
وتاريخ تاريخ العبرانيين هذا موجود في
التوراه
والتورات هذه هي نص
بين قوسين في فوارق ولكن هو نص يهودي هو
الذي يقدم روايه اليهود لتاريخهم
في فتره الى الفتره الحديثه لم تكن لنا
امكانيه لكتابه التاريخ اليهود الا من
خلال اليهود انفسهم
يعني اخيرا تم اكتشاف حوليات الاشوريه
والنصوص الفرعونيه ولكن الى فتره فتره
طويله لم يكن حتى كلمه الشعوب الساميه
واللغات الساميه كلها استمدها العلماء
الالمان من نص التوراتي
نافذتنا حول تاريخ اليهود كانت مكتوبه
بنصوص او بيد بيد بيد يهوديه والمشكل في
هذا في الحقيقه عندما اشرت الى هذا اردت
ابين نقطه مهمه لانه يستهدف منها الدراسات
العربيه الاسلاميه مثلا ولكن يتغاضى البعض
على انها تنطبق ايضا على الدراسات
اليهوديه وعن تاريخ اليوم عندما اقول انهم
كتبوا تاريخهم يعني انهم كتبوا ما ارادوا
ان يعتقدوا انه واقع
او ارادوا ما كتب ما اعتقدوا انه وقع من
تاريخهم او ارادوا ان يعتقدوا انه وقع
او ارادوا لغيرهم من الشعوب المحيطه بهم
او لابنائهم في المستقبل ان يعتقد انه هم
يقدمون التوراه تقدم سرديه يهوديه باقلام
يهوديه حول تاريخ شعب شعب اسرائيل ونحن
نعلم ان الكتابه غير التدوين الكتابه خطيه
التدوين في عمل الذاكره في حفظ في نسيان
في في تفضيل لروايه على اخرى فما جمعته
التوراه وما هو موجود في التوراه هو تدوين
لتاريخ شعب اسرائيل
في كل اللغات وفي كل الشعوب
ينطبق الامر ايضا على المسلمين طبقا ولكن
بالنسبه لنص التوراتي يجب عندما نقرا
التوراه يجب ان نفهم انها سرديه توراتيه
يهوديه لليهود عن انفسهم عم اعتقدوا انه
وقع من تاريخهم او ارادوا ان يعتقد انه
وقع او ارادوا لغيرهم من المحيطين بهم ان
يعتقدوا لان التدوين هو غير الكتاب عندما
تقول تدوين تقول ذاكره وتقول امكانيه
للنسيان
ولتفضيل روايه على اخرى وهذا هو المقصود
بالحقيقه
لكي يفهم المهتم بالتاريخ اليهودي انه
بسبب سرديه ماء انتصرت ربما على سرديات
اخرى البحث الاركيولوجي التاريخي اليوم
يبين
ان ما يسمى بالتاريخ التوراتي هو تاريخ
المقدس وليس تاريخا احترافيا
التاريخ المقدس هو كتب لغايات دينيه لغايه
لهوتيه هو الانتصار لتصور ديني معين وليس
بالضروره مثل نعطيك مثال فكره فكره الخروج
وانشقاق البحر
وكل وكثير من الاحداث الموجوده في النص
التوراتي بطبيعه الحال البحث التاريخي
المعاصر او ما يسمى بالبحث التاريخي في
العهد القديم له فيها روايات او فيه نظر
يختلف تماما عما هو موجود وربما يكذب ما
هو موجود في الروايه او في السرديه
بالسرديه التورته حيث هذا هذا
طبعا طبعا ولكن هذا موضوع ثاني موضوع ثاني
لماذا موضوع ثاني
لانه وهذا انا كتبت مقال
بعنوان لماذا يخشى المسلمون النقل
التاريخي
علاش في هذا الموضوع لانه من خلال نظري في
النصوص اليهوديه وفي القضايا تتعلق
بالثقافه المسيحيه
المسلمون يفرحون عندما يجدون نقدا للتوراه
ونقدا للتاريخ اليهودي ويهللون ويكبرون
هذه التوراه محرفه وهذا الانبياء هم قتل
وهو الى اخره ونفس الشيء بالنسبه للمسيحيه
وان البحث الحديث بين ان التوراه معموله
ومكذوبه وان المسيح الاناجيل كذلك ولكن
المسلمون عندما ياتي الامر لتطبيق هذه
المناهج التي يهللون لها عندما يتحدثون عن
الاسلام
نقف
ونخاف
ونرهب ونتهيب وهذا منذ قرنين من الزمان
لكن يعني في القران وفي الاسلام وجود
التحرير في التوراه مذكور فمقبول عندنا
هذه الفكره
واذا كنا نبغى نتكلم عن الحديث والسنه ففي
يعني واحد انه هي قائمه على اصول
شديده
الاهتمام بضبطها
ولكن الاخذ والعطى فيها ممكن البحث فيه
لكن في القران برضو في تعهد بحفظه
فما يمكن معاملته بالمثل يعني لهذا هو
نقطه خلافي معك في النقطه هذه ولكن نحن
الان دخلنا الى المنطقه المحرمه التي
تحتاج الى شيء من الهدوء وكما يقول الجحفظ
لبيان
في هذا الموضوع موضوع التحريف بكل بساطه
التحريف في المعنى الذي تتحدث عنه لم
يستقر الا في مرحله متاخره من التاريخ
الاسلامي عندما ترجع الى الموضوع هذا في
المقرن الاول وفي القرن الثاني
وحتى الى فتره بعد ذلك بكثير ستجد ان هذا
الموضوع كان الموضوع اخذ ورد ما تتحدث عنه
هو ما استقر في الضمير الاسلامي
اعطيك مثال القران عندما يتحدث عن
اسمح لي اتوسع في هذه النقطه بكيفيه لان
الغايه هي ان يقتنع
المشاهد بمعقوليه ما اقول لا اقول بصحه ما
اقول ولكن بماقوليه ما اقول
القران يستعمل للحديث عن التوراه في هذه
النقطه بالذات خمسه كلمات
يتحدث عن الليل
يلون الكتاب بالسنتهم
يتحدث عن
يقول كلمه معموله محرفه تبديل
وفي كلمه اخرى حسنا هناك خمسه كلمات
استعملها القران للحديث عن هذا الموضوع
فهل المقصود بالتحريف هو التغيير اللفظ في
التوراه
اجيبك لا
المسلم
طوال تاريخهم عندما نعود الى هذه المواضيع
ونرى ماذا كتبه المسلمون
سنرى ان الطيار الذي قال بان التحريف واقع
في الالفاظ هو التيار
ابرز من دافع عن هذه الفكره التاريخيا هو
ابن حزم الاندلسي
في الفيصلي في الملل والاهواء
وكتب كل هذا الكتاب ليبين فكره ان هذا
التحريف في التوراه واقع في الالفاظ
وكان يقول انه هذا التحريف موجود انتهاء
لانه موجود في 5 مواضع
ثم نزل بهذين الى موضعين ثم الى نص واحد
هذا النص اسمها ازينو يعرفه المتخصص في
هذا ولكن عند مقارنته بالنصوص الموجوده
الان انا جد شيء كبير ووجد اعتراف من
علماء عصره ومن علماء الاندلس
ومن علماء المالكيه وعلى راسهم القاضي
الجياني
وكان يسمي هذا يسمى ما قام به ابن حزم
يسميه بالمعضل يقول ابن حزم انت اوقعت
نفسك في مطبات لا مخرج منها
لانك لو اردت اثبات التحريف لا يجب ان
يكون عندك اللص الاصلي لتقارنا ما به وقع
وهذا امر لا يمكن القيام به فاوقعت نفسك
في المعضل هناك شخص اخر ذكي يمثل راس
التيار في الحقيقه
يمثل العلامه ابن خلدون صاحب المقدم يقول
في نص شهير
ما عاد الله ان تعمد امه من الامم الى
كتابها المنزلي فتبدله
يعني من المنطق يقول انه لا يمكن لامه
تعتبر ان كتابها مقدس ثم تعبث به معاذ
الله ان تعمد امه من الامم الى كتابها
المنزل
فتبدله الا ان يكون ذلك على سبيل الغفله
وعدم الضبط من نوع اخطاء النساق الى غير
ذلك وهذا امر امر وارد في كل الكتب وفي كل
وهناك مبحث كبير داخل التقاليد اليهوديه
يتحدث عما يسمى باخطاء النسخ 13
باللغه العبريه وتحدث عنها ابن حزم
ويعرفها الى غير ذلك هذا الموضوع هذا
الموضوع موضوع في الحقيقه عندما يتخصص فيه
الانسان يفهم انه ما يقال وما هو شائع بين
الناس فيه نظر
طيب بالنسبه
لليهود يعني نحن تحدثنا فيهم بشكل باخر
وودي انه برضو احنا ننتقل الى المستجدات
نتكلم عنها لكن للحديث عن هذه ودي نرجع
للتاصيل بعض الاشياء لما نتكلم عن اليهود
يعرف من هم اليهود
قبل كل شيء هناك ثلاثه اشياء
ثم العبرانيون
امر مختلف
فما بنو اسرائيل شيء مختلف وفما شيء اسمه
اليهود الثلاث مختلف الاشياء يجب المتخصص
ان يفهم ان هناك فرق بين هؤلاء
العبرانيون لصله لهم بهذه اليهوديه التي
نعرفها اليوم
في مشكله تاريخيه من هم
هل هو اشتقاق من عبير ومن خبيره الى اخره
ولكن
البعض يريد ان يربطهم بابراهيم ورحلته
رحله الاباء ما يسمى بالاباء ولكن بنو
اسرائيل هم هو الفتره التي يتحدث فيها عن
هذه الجماعه في مصر
يعني
بني اسرائيل او بني اسرائيل في اللغه في
اللغه العبريه اليهوديه واليهود كمصطلح
ظهر مع السبيل
مع مع السبيل البابلي لا يمكن الحديث عن
يهوديه حقيقيه الا مع سبيل البابلي لماذا
مع سبيل البابلي لانه عندها ما نقول دين
تشكل دين يعني تشكل مؤسسات
لبس احكام فقه مؤسسات كنيس الى غير ذلك كل
ما هو موجود سبق هو اشكال بدائيه لم تظهر
اليهوديه كمؤسسه كدين عندما تقول مسيحيه
تقول كنيسه مثلا
في احكام فيها في اليهوديه احكام حلال
وحرام وكفاءه الى هذا كله تم تنظيمه في
الفتره فتره الشتات ما يسمى في التاريخ
اليهودي او في التصور اليهودي انه انه
شداد لانه بالنسبه اليهود في خمسه مرات من
الشتات وفي مرتين خراب للهيكل كما يسميهم
هما على كل حال هذا يجب ان يكون واضحا
اليهوديه هي مرحله مرحله السبيل البابلي
وما بعدها يمكن الحديث عن عن هؤلاء اليهود
واليهودي القرنين يتحدث احيانا عن اليهود
بدون تعريف ويذكر لي كلمه اليهود مره
تقريبا بالتعريف او مرتين فهذا يجب ان
يكون يكون واضحا اليهوديه التقليديه
تقوم على كتاب هذا الكتاب هو التوراه ولكن
هذه لنقل الكلام عام التوراه هي مجموع
التوراه التقليديه عندما كل الدوره
التقليديه التوراه التي يؤمن بها جمهور
اليهود اليوم
والتي هي معروفه بالنسخه الماسوره
الماسوره علماء الماسوره هم علماء الذين
ضبطوا النص التوراتي بشكل نهائي
وفق تقاليد مدرسه للتنقيط هي مدرسه ابن
عاشر وهذه استمر الامر الى الف سنه تقريبا
بعد بعد الميلاد ثمانيه تسعه قرون لانه
تاريخ النص التوراتي وتاريخ طويل يعني
تقريبا
استمر من القرن الثامن قبل الميلاد الى
الثاني بعد الميلاد فتره طويله نسبيا
طويله جدا في الحقيقه لكي يتشكل هذا النص
بصيغته التي نعرفها الحاليه عند الجمهور
اليهود
ولكن هذه التوراه مكونه من 24 كتاب
او 22 كتاب لان البعض اليهود يدمج اربعه
كتب في كتابين لاسباب رمزيه حتى يقابل
العدد 22 كتاب 22 حرف في اللغه في اللغه
العبريه في خمسه كتب هي الاسفار الخمسه
وفيها كتب الانبياء اللي هي 11 كتاب
والمكتوبات ثمانيه ثمانيه كتب المجموع هو
هو ما يحصل من من هذه الاعداد خمسه 11
وثمانيه
و11
وهذه الكتب بطبيعه الحال يجب ان نفهم انها
ليست هي التوراه السامريه الثوره هي سته
كتب والتوراه اليونانيه تختلف فيها زياده
كتب وهي باللغه اليونانيه ترجمت في عهد
البطالمه في عهد الحضور اليوناني في في
مصر وفي
الخلفاء خلفاء الاسكندر ثم هناك نسخه اخرى
تسمى النسخه اليونانيه للتحولت الى نسخه
اللاتينيه تسمى او النسخه الى هناك نسخ
كثيره ولكن من النسخه الرسميه التي يتعبد
بها اليهود التقليديون هي النسخه
الماسوراتيه التي
تم الطباعتها
على جمهور اليهود وعنا نسخه اكاديميه في
الحقيقه
معروفه بما يسمى
لانه صنعت في مدينه
الالمانيه وهي النسخه المحققه انشانا
نتحدث بعد عمليه التدقيق لانه احدى
الاشياء العلم الحديث هي محاوله انشاء
النسخه النسخه العلميه للكتاب الكتاب
المقدس ونشات ما يسمى بالنقد التاريخي
للنصوص
هذه هي هذه هي الامور الاساسيه في التوراه
مع الاسف نحب نوضح شيء هو ان المسلمين لا
يعرفون هذه الامور او حتى التسميات
ان التوراه القرانيه غير التوراه اليهوديه
كثير من المسلمين يتحدثون عن التوراه
وكانهم يتصورون انهم يتحدثون عن التوراه
اليهود في الحقيقه لا يتحدثون عن دورات
اليوم يتحدثون عن تطورات القران اذا كلمه
توراه في العبريه تعني اما 22 كتاب او
خمسه كتب بحسب السياق
احيانا اليهود يقول ترا وهو يقصد الاصفار
الخمسه
اذا اراد التدقيق يقول ترى خمسه كتب او
خمش بالعبريه خماش يعني خمسه المقصود
باصفر خمسه او يقول تناخ يعني الترى نون
المكتوبات فتنختعني 24 كتاب ترى تعني خمسه
فقط او الكل ثم ايضا
كثير من المسلمين يتحدثون عن كتارات
يقولون
سفر العدد سفر الخروج وكل هذه التسميه
يونانيه وليست تسميات التوراتي يعني يعني
ورثها المسلمون من الاوساط المسيحيه اما
الوسيطه عن طريق النشاطره مثلا المسيحيين
في بغداد وغيرها او من خلال
الترجمات الترجمه الحديثه لانه اليهود لا
يتحدثون عن هذه التسميه لتسميه جاءت من
الترجمات بالترجمه بالمناسبه التوراه لا
يوجد لدينا اليوم اي نسخه اصليه
ابدا ما هو موجود هو نسخ على نسخ على
النسخ عندنا نسخ قديمه
كانت في نسخه في في روسيا ولكن ايضا مثلا
اقدم النسخ لصفر اشعياء مثلا اذا موجوده
في
عثرنا عليها سنه 47
او عثر عليها عام 1947 في مغاور قمران
عمران كانت في تلك الفتره تابعه للاردن او
لمملكه شرق شرق شرق الاردن
وكان احد الرواد الرعاه عفوا يتبع الشياه
فظاعه احدى شياهي ودخلت الى احدى المغارات
فاراد اخراجها فرما ببعض الحجاره فوجد ان
هناك صدى ورنين لهذه الحجاره
فدخل فوجد جرار
وهذه الجرار كانت كانت تعتبر اعظم اكتشاف
في العصر الحديث
لانها قدمت لنا اقدم النصوص حول هذه
الجماعات المسيونيه واقدم النصوص للنصوص
التوراتيه ولانه لم يكن يعرف القيمه باعها
لبعض التجار
الاثار
فصادف المرء احد اليهود البريطانيين اسمه
سلمون شختر
فعرف قيمتها وقام بشرائها وتحويل جزء منها
كبير الى الى بريطانيا ثم حولت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ولم تفتح لجمهور
اللافعات
وانما بقيت حكرا على المتخصصين الى غير
ذلك فالمهم انه ليست لنا نسخه نسخه اصليه
وانما هي نسخ على نسخ واستمر البحث وهي
مجال البحث وللدراسه يجب ان يكون هذا
واضحا بالنسبه الى من يريد الاهتمام
اليهوديه تقوم على هذا النص الاساسي وتقوم
على اشياء اخرى تقوم على فكره العهد
العهد شعب الله ما يسمى بشعب الله المختار
او البريت باللغه باللغه العبريه
وهناك بطبيعه الحال تاويلات يهوديه لهذا
المعنى هل هو مراد به الاستعلاء ام مراد
به التواضع لان هذه
الرساله
حمل السماوات والارض يعني والناس فابينها
وحملها اليهودي
ولذلك هو شعب المختار على كل حال هناك
وفكره الميثاق عفوا فكره الارض فكره الارض
هذه
المختار كيف بدات بدات مع العهد الذي
انشاه اله اسرائيل مع مع ابراهيم يعني منذ
البدايه في الحقيقه هي رحله خروج ابراهيم
من اور من جنوب يعني من قريبه من شط العرب
يعني من تلك الرحله خرج بمفرده ثم بعائلته
واستمرت هذه الرحله طويله وفي هذه الرحله
اعطاه ارضا وعاده بارض
وعده بانه سيكثروا نسله
وسيجعله شعبا مختار هذه الاشياء الثلاثه
كانت تحتاج الى تحيين في كل مره
مع ابراهيم ثم مع اسحاق ثم مع يعقوب ثم مع
موسى ثم
نوع من تحين العقود كان ما نسميه اليوم في
لغه في لغه رجال القانون
الشعب المختار
والعهد والعهد الختان هو هو دليل على
العهد ان وجدت العاده في الشعوب الشرق
الاوسط القديم هو انه الملوك عندما يكتبون
عهودا كانوا يكتبونها مثلا بالدم
كانوا يجرحون انفسهم
ويقومون بعمليه اليوم بالامضاء
فالختام هو تذكير بهذا العهد هو جرح يقوم
به الانسان في جسده
بتذكير ولذلك يسمى
ونحن نسميه بالعربيه
لا يفتتن
وايضا هو سنه هو هو عهد العهد الذي اقامه
اله الاله
اله اسرائيل مع شعب مع شعب اسرائيل انه
كلمه اله اسرائيل في الحقيقه نحن لم نكن
نعرفه لم يظهر الى اسرائيل باسمه الا في
مصر
حسب التوراه
لانه في البدايه كان يقول التوراه عندما
تتحدث عن هذا الاله لا تسميه تقول الهك
واله ابائك مثلا
يسال اليهود مثلا يسلوا من هو ما اسمك
يقول اشير
انا الذي انا
في مصر
في الخروج في فتره الخروج سيقول انا اله
انا اله اسمي
مناجده اليوم بكلمه بالعربيه ياهو او يهوى
اليهود لا ينطقون هذا الاسم حرام ان ينتقد
الاسم ويعوضونه دائما وابدا بتسميه اخرى
يقولون
سيدي
او الوهم او شيء ولكن لا يقول كلمه هل لان
هذا الاسم هو معرع عن الحركات
ويعتبر من الكبائر ان ينتقل الانسان باسمه
لانه من جمله الاشياء وهذا الاسم لا ينطق
الا في الهيكل في مكان معظم من الهيكل
وينطقه
او الكاهن الاعظم وبما ان هذا الهيكل غير
موجود ويجب ان يبنى مره اخرى فان جزء كبير
من الشرائع اليهوديه معطله
ولذلك اقول دائما لطلبتي
هذا الهيكل سيبنى الهيكل هذا سيبنى على
انقاذ المسجد الاقصى هذه حتميه تورتي
وحتميه يهوديه يجب ان يفهم العرب هذا
يجب ان يفهم السياسيون هذا لن تنفك
الجماعات اليهوديه ولا الا عندما يتم هدم
الهيكل
لانه جزء من الشرائع اليهوديه معطل
ولا يستقيم الا ببناء هذا الهيكل بعد
الخراب الاول والقربان الهاشميه والخراب
والهيكل لا يمكن بناء
السرديه اليهوديه تقول انه ان الهيكل
المسجد الاقصى بني على على على انقاذ
الهيكل وبطبيعه الحال والبحث جاري وينقبون
صباح مساء ويوم الاحد كما يقال للبحث عن
دلائل على وجود هذا الهيكل
هو هيكل الذي بناه سليمان
وفيه مثلا في مقر مقر
نسميه يعني
المحكمه الشرعيه او وزاره العدل في
التقاليد في التقاليد اليهوديه وهي امر
اساسي يعني القضاء الشرعي معطل يعني
استعارت اليهوديه وتاريخها باشكال بديله
مؤقته
ولكن تنتظر هذا الهيكل يقام لتعود هذه
المؤسسات الدينيه التي عرفت اليهوديه في
داخل هذا داخل هذا داخل هذا الهيكل الارض
فكره الارض قبل الارض العائد ما هو العهد
مش طبيعه العهد هذا هو العهد ساعطيك ارضا
لك ولنسلك من بعدك ابديا عهدا ابديا هذا
العهد هو مع نسل
اسحاق ابراهيم من اسحاق هو عهد ابدي لا
يمكن ان يتوقف لسبب الاسباب
وبمقتضى هذا العهد ساعطيك هذه الارض وما
هي هذا العرض الارض هذه الارض هذه هي
في البدايه عندما خرج ابراهيم لم تكن
واضحه اذهب وساريك هذه الارض شيئا فشيئا
وابراهيم نفسه يقر ان هذه الارض هي
التوراه تقر ان هذه هي ارض غربه كان غريبا
في هذه الارض ليست ارضه
كانت فيها الحثيين والاموريين وشعوب اخرى
كثيره
وفيها ايضا ما يسمى بالفلسطينيين او
العمالقه الفلسطيين بعض يخطئ ويعتبر انهم
الفلسطينيين ولكن هم الفلسطينيين الفلسطين
بالفرنسيه
وبالانجليزيه وهم من شعوب البحر يعني من
بحر ايجي والى اخره استوطنوا تلك الفتره
فهذه بلاد كنعان
وحتى اللغه التي كانت تستعمل حتى الابريه
القديمه كانت تسمى بلاشون كنعان او لسانه
كنعان
فالتورات تقر بانها ارض غروبه
وفرعون ذهب الى مصر ثم عاد الى الى بلاد
كنعان واشترى ارضا لدفن زوجته رحيل من هذا
الحث الى غير ذلك ولكن
ولا توجد كلمه ارض موعوده في التوراه
اطلاق كلمه موعوده صحيح هناك حديث عن هذه
الارض واهميتها ولكن استعبار ما نجده
اليوم من كلمه ارض موعوده لا وجود له في
التوراه العباره نفسها ولكن المعنى موجود
انك ستلت هذه الارض وساعطيك هذه الارض
ملكا ابديا
بودي نوضح للساده المشاهدين فكره مهمه جدا
دائما اوضحها لطلبتي
هذه الارض قبل ان تكون ارضا موعوده يجب ان
تتحول الى ارض مكتسبه بقوه بالقوه بقوه
السلاح
سمير بالفرنسيه
يتم دخولها بالقوه يعني هناك فرق بين ان
يكون موعود بهذه الارض ولكن كيف ستحصل
عليه
هناك
النصوص التوراتيه والتلميذ بعد ذلك
مسائل كثيره
في في مؤتمر في الامم المتحده
سنوات تكلم المندوب الاسرائيلي
اسمه داني دانون
وبامكان الساده المشاهدين ان يعودوا الى
هذا الفيديو هو موجود على اليوتيوب وبصيغه
بنسخه جيده
في معقل القانون الدولي
يعني عندما تكون في معقل الدولي المفروض
ان تتحدث بلغه القانون الدولي
اسرائيل انشئت بمقتضى قانون الدولي بمقتضى
قرار التقسيم 47
في رده على احد
الممثلين احدى الدول الذي عاب عليه
الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه وحق الفلسطينيين
في الاراضي الى غير ذلك ما الذي فعل داني
الدانون اخذ نسخه من التوراه وضعها امامه
لبس الكبه اليهوديه وبدا يقرا من صفر
التكوين
بمواضع مشهوره هذه الارض
ملك لك
ولنسلك من بعدك اعطي هذه الارض ملكا ابدي
يقول ان شهاده ملكيتنا لهذه الارض تاتي من
هنا
من هذا النص الديني تصور انت لو انه اي
مندوب عربي اسلامي رفع القران وقال مثلا
الارض يرث هو عبادي الصالحه
قمه القطرسه
الدوله التي قامت بمقتضى قرار التقسيم
يقوم مندوبه برفع النسخه من التوراه ويقول
هذا هو شهاده ملكيه هذا دفتر خانه كما قال
باللغه العثمانيه
القديمه
لما نتكلم عن الاسلام نلقى في داخل الدين
الاسلامي في قسمين اليوم
الاكبر في سنه شيعه وفي التفاصيل داخل
مثلا في المذاهب وغيره في اليهود هل في
هذه التصنيف طبعا طبعا
افترقت اليهود
الا واحد يعني منذ القديم كالحديث عن
الفرق في الشقاق في
كل يعني حديث الفرق الناجيه بدا بالحديث
عن الفرق اليهوديه ولكن بالعوده الى
التاريخ اليهودي نفسه بطبيعه الحال اليهود
الانشقاق اول انشقاق وقع بعد وفاه
سليمان داود بعد داود مرحله داود وسليمان
وانقسموا الى مملكه بالشمال ومملكه مملكه
اسرائيل ومملكه هدى اذا هذا انقسام اول
ولكن وادى بطبيعه الحال بعد ذلك الى ظهور
الغزو الاشوري والبابلي والفارسي ثم الغزو
اليوناني والروماني الى غير ذلك لهذه
الارض ولكن هناك انقسمات
يعني داخل في تلك الفتره يعني في الفتره
الرومانيه نعطيك مثال كان في ما يسمى
باليهوديه الصندوقيه فرقه
هناك
فرقه اخرى
[موسيقى]
لينتمي لها السيد المسيح
تنذكر الاسم متاعها فرقتين او ثلاث ولكن
مثلا
فراغات في الذكر احيانا في الفتره
الاسلاميه مثلا ظهرت لعرفه اليهوديه كان
في اليهود السامره مثلا اليهود السميره
كانوا كانوا يهود المجموع اليهود يكفرون
يكثرون يهود الساميرات لانهم يعتبرون هم
من اليهود الذين نتعاملوا مع الاشوريين
اذا هم نوع من الخونه في احكام قاسيه تمنع
الاتصال بين بين الجماعتين ومقرهم الان هم
في نابلس في فلسطين
ولا يعترفون بالقدس
يعترفون به ان يقول ان المقر هو ليس القدس
وانما جبل جبل جريزين في في في نابلس ولهم
توراه اخرى غير التوراه اليهوديه ولكن
اكبر فرقه عرفناها في تاريخنا الاسلامي
ظهرت في القرن الثالث
في عهد الدوله العباسيه هي طائفه القراءين
هذه الطائفه مهمه جدا
[موسيقى]
وزعيمها هو عنان بن داود
عنان بن داود هذا هذا
يختلفون عن بقيه اليهود في انهم لا يؤمنون
الا بالتوراه يرفضون التلمود
ان التوراه بالنسبه اليهود هي التوراه هي
فما نعيما في
او الطائرات التي على الفم وهي تلمون
تراشي بكتاب او التوراه التي هي المكتوبه
اللي هي الاصفار الخمسه الى 24 يكتب
فالتلمود هو التلمود والتوراه الشفويه
عنده اسم التوراه الشفويه
فهؤلاء لا يقبلون بالتوراه الشفويه ولا ما
يقبلون فقط بالتوراه المكتوبه ولذلك يسمون
انفسنا
كلمه قرار
الى غير ذلك لا يؤمنون الا بالمقرا اي
بالتوراه
ويقال ان احد
الاسباب نشاه هذه الفرقه لانهم كانوا
ظاهريه يشبهون المذهب الظاهري لياخذون
بظاهر ولا ياخذون بالقياس الى غير ذلك
خلافات مع اليهود بتاثير بتاثير تاثر عنان
بن داود بداود الظاهري في بغداد
واستمرت هذه الفرقه
وانتجت اثار كبيره في الفقه
وبعضهم مثل يعقوب القرقيساني في كتاب
الانوار والمراقب هو الوحيد الذي كان يقرب
بنبوه النبي ويقول انه نبي صحيح ولكنه نبي
للعرب
يقرب بهذه النبوه
وكان في خلاف كبير بين الربانيين الجمهور
اليهود والقراءين طوال القرون الوسط حتى
انه عندما تم افتاده في العراق قاموا
بثوره فتره معينه ضد الخلافه ضد بعض
الخلفاء استقروا عندما لجا الامويون الى
الى الى الى الى الاندلس ايضا بعض
القرائين في فتره اللاحقات توجهوا الى
الاندلس
وابن حسب الاندلسي وهو من كبار الذين ردوا
على اليهود استقى جزءا كبيرا من الماده
التي تستعملها في رد اليهوديه الربانيه من
هؤلاء القرائين المناهضين لليهوديه
الربانيه الموجودين في طلبيرا تلافيرا وفي
اماكن مختلفه من من الاندلس ان كان هناك
تمازج وحتى في الحرب العالميه الثانيه
النازيه مثلا اخذت بالفكره التي تقول ان
هؤلاء ليسوا
يهوديين من اليهود ولذلك لم تطالهم
العمليات التعقب التي قام بها
وهم الان في الحقيقه عددهم قليل جدا لا
يتجاوز 700 نفر
تماما كاليهود السميره القل عددهم
موجودين في بعض منهم في في في كانوا
موجودين بكثره في مصر
ولكن الوسطى بطبيعه الحالات الموجودين في
المتحده وبعضهم موجود في اسرائيل
يعني اكبر انشقاق بطبيعه الحال ثم نشات في
الابتداء من عصر النهضه عصر الانوار
اليهوديه نتحدث عن اليهوديه الحديثه
طوائف اخرى يهوديه تتسمى باليهوديه
الارثوذكسيه
فكره الارثوذكسيه دي كلمه جديده في
الحقيقه
واليهوديه الليبراليه وهذه الحركات
اليهوديه ظهرت مع ما يسمى
بامر مهم لانه
يدفعنا شيئا فشيء الحديث عن العصر الحديث
وان نشاه اسرائيل والحركه الصهيونيه
اليهود ظل تاريخهم تاريخا هادئا
لانه تؤاد فيه
يعني طوال الى حدود القرن الثامن عشر
حياه اليهودي حياه بسيط معرفه بنصوص دينيه
من التوراه ومعرفه بالاحكام وانتهى الامر
قراءه نصوص بعض الفقهاء وبعض النصوص
الدينيه
للثوراتيه وللشروح
سيعرف هؤلاء اليهود هز في القرن 18
لماذا
لانه بدات في اوروبا ما يسمى بالاوف
كليرونج او
لايتمنت عصر الانوار الاوروبي الذي بدا
بالاساس في برلين
تعبير الفكريه لهذا العصر الانوار
الاوروبي بدا في المانيا اخذت تعبيرات
سياسيه واجتماعيه في فرنسا بعد ذلك ولكن
وفلسفيه في المانيا وهذه العصر الانوار
هذا في الحقيقه جاء نتيجه لثورتين سابقتين
ظهرت ما يسمى بالثوره العلميه الكوبرنيكي
اوروبا تتغير نظرتها للكون
والفيزياء والكيمياء والفضائل غير ذلك
ولكن في القرن الخامس عشر بدات اوروبا
تعرف ثوره اخرى اولى هي الثوره يسمى بنهضه
عسل النهضه النهضه يجب ان نفرق بين ثلاثه
اشياء بين النهضه
والاصلاح والثور الذي مفاهيم مختلف تماما
اللحظه الالمانيه النهضه الايطاليه بدات
في جنوى في الموانئ وكانت هذه النهضه اولا
كانت
بالاساس
نخبويه طالت النخب ولا تطال العمل عامه
الناس
وهذه النهضه ايضا كانت تحت رقابه البابويه
يعني ما زالت الكنيسه سلطه بدات بوادر نقد
تين ورجال الدين الى غير ذلك
وكانت هذه النهضه ايضا
عقيمه من النار عفوا هي من الناحيه
الجماليه هي خصبه
العماره الى اخره
بدات بعد هذه الفتره فتره النهضه كما قلت
عصر
الثوره الثوره العلميه في القانون 18
ستبدا ثوره ثوره فلسفيه ستاتي بافكار
جديده في مجال الفلسفه بالاساس من بين هذه
الافكار فكره العقد الاجتماعي
ان العلاقه بين الحاكم والمحكوم هي علاقه
عقد
ستبدا فكره بدايه نشاه الدوله الامم
الدوله الدوله الامه في تاريخ في تاريخ
اوروبا وبدات فكره العقد ان العلاقه بين
بين الحاكم المحكوم في علاقه يعني
وبدات هذه الفتره فتره الثوره على الثوره
على على الكنيسه وبدا ستعرف شيئا فشيء
ظهور ما يعرف بالبروتستانتيه
هذه الفتره و صدور فكره اخرى في الفلسفه
السياسيه هي فكره المواطنه
هذا امر امر جلل في تاريخ البجالي وفي
تاريخ الاسلام وفي تاريخ تاريخ اليهودي ان
المواطن الصالح لا تحدد لا يحدده الدين
او لا يحدده الدين بدرجه اولى يحدده مدى
قيامه بواجباته وحقوقه ومطالبته له حقوق
اصبح الانسان الوسيط الاوروبي حقوق
وله واجبات
ومن اوكد هذه الواجبات
القيام بدفع الضرائب مثلا
فليس
للدين دور اساسي في تحديد المواطن
وهذا سيدفع الاقليات في اوروبا الى
امام تحديات
من بين الاقليه اليهوديه في المانيا
سينشا في المانيا عن طريق شخص
مشهور جدا في تاريخ هو موشي مندلسم
هذا يسمى اب الانوار اليهوديه في انوار
كبرى اوروبيه مسيحيه التقاليد او نشات من
رحم الثقافه المسيحيه ولكن هناك
داخلها
انوار يهوديه تتسمى الهسكله حركه الهسكله
يعني
انسان عنده في يعني له مسكه من عقل او شيء
من هذا من هذا القبيل يعني هناك عمل عقلي
هذا مش منديلسون كان امام امام امام مشكل
وقد بدات رياح الانوار رياح المواطنه
والعقد الاجتماعي ماذا سنفعل نحن اليهود
الذين نعيشهم جدا نعيش
وستبدا مشكله ازليه عند اليهود في الحقيقه
لليوم عبر عنهم ريال شارون بطريقه اخرى
وعبر عنها
[موسيقى]
الصهيونيه المراجعيه
ايضا بقضيه جرجر الحديدي يعني ماذا سنفعل
هل سنبقى في الكيتو ام نخرج الى هذا
العالم
ستنتهي فكره رجل الدين التقليدي الذي
عرفتها اليهوديه وستنشا فكره جديده اسمها
فكره المثقف
فكره جديده مفهوم جديد هذا الذي سيكون له
كما يقول علماء المسلمين له مشاركه في
علوم عصره
سيصبح ثقافه ليس ثقافه فقط هي ثقافه الدين
وانما فيها الموسيقى
فيها ربما المسرح فيها الفلسفه فيها الطب
فيها كل هذه العلوم الدنيويه
فهل سيقبل اليهود الالماني
ان تسير حياته وفق قوانين مدنيه
هذا يطرح
هو احدى الاشياء التي يعتز بها اليهود هي
هذه الهلاقه وهي التي شكلت طوال حياته
منذ منذ منذ انتهاء الوجود السياسي في
فلسطين هو هو يتبع تعاليم
هو يعتبر انه بقائه في التاريخ هو نتيجه
تمسك بهذه الاحكام اليهوديه
فهل يؤدي هذا هل يؤدي هذا الخروج
والاحتكام الى قوانين الدوله الالمانيه
الى شيء من الى الانصهار
الى خوف الذوبان اليهود عنده مشكله اساسيه
مشكله ازليه هي الخوف من الانصهار
هو يريد ان يظل يهوديا في عالم متشعب
كان من الذين دعوا هؤلاء اليهود الى
الخروج من
واستنشاق هواء عليل وثقافه جديده
ودعاهم وقام بترجمه النص التوراتي الى
الالمانيه
محاولا ان يخرج هؤلاء اليهود الى الى
ثقافه الالمانيه ويقرب يقرب اليهوديه من
الالمان ذوي الثقافه الجرمانيه واللغه الى
اخره
وكتب كتبا في الحقيقه في هذا في هذا
الاتجاه
وان بقي هناك طيار يرى انه محافظ يريد ان
يبقى كما هو لانه يخاف
من غرائب الصدف انه انه اولاد ولا اثنين
صاروا مسيحيين
مثل ما وقع
كتب كتاب ايميل في التربيه
واولاد وعاشوا مشردين
على كل
المهم انه هذا هذين الطياران
طيار يريد ان يبقى وطيار يريد ان يخرج
العالم الحديث
وربحنا منه هذا الطيار شيء مهم جدا نحن
مسلمون
هو تيار عرف في المانيا
ربما بعض الناس يعرف الاسماء ولكن لا يفهم
من اين جاءت هذه السلاله السلاله
المستشرقين مثلا الكل يعرف تقريبا مهتمين
بالدراسات الاسلاميه يعرف شخص اسمه مثلا
كبير
هؤلاء ينتمون
وعشرات من الاخرين انت انت كلهم موجودين
في في بولونيا وموجودين في في النمسا او
موجودين في المانيا او في المجر بالاساس
ينتمون الى مدرسه تسمى بالعبريه حكمات
اسرائيل او حكمه اسرائيل او تسمى
بالالمانيه
نشاه علم جديد بين اوساط اليهود يريد ان
يفهم اليهوديه بطريقه حديثه
ونشا علماء متشبعون بالثقافه الاوروبيه
الحديثه
وكانوا ينظرون بعين النقد الى التوراه
والى التلمود
يعني هو اشبه تلقوا تشبه تعليما معلما
بلغتنا اليوم
واعتبر ان اشياء كثيره في اليهوديه يجب ان
تنتهي وان تضمحل لانه لم يعد لها معنى في
العالم الحديث الى غير ذلك
وعادوا الى تاريخ دراسه تاريخ اليهود عبر
العصور فوجدوا ان جزءا كبيرا من تاريخهم
مربوط بالعالم الاسلامي
فتخصصوا في الدراسات العربيه الاسلاميه
وانجبوا لنا وانتجت هذه المدرسه لنا كبار
المستشرقين الذين
ننهلوا في كثير من معارفهم فيما يتعلق
بتحقيق اللصوص وفي الدراسات الاسلاميه الى
غير ذلك
يعني جزء من الاستشراق التقليدي قد ما قبل
77 لانه ستتغير الامور بشكل جذري سينتهي
هذا التقليد الاستشراقي القديم
ونحن شنعنا على هؤلاء لانهم اما انهم يهود
او لانهم يشككون في الاسلام والشبوات
بينما قدم جزء كبير منهم قدم خدمات جديده
للاسلام والمسلمين على الاقل في باب تحقيق
النصوص وخصوصا اشتراك الالماني لانه كما
تعرف كان عن صديق اسمه
ولكن يعرف المستشرق اوتشبيس هذا المانيا
شهير كان يقول انك لو سالت مستشرقا
المانيا عن من هي عائشه سيقول انها عائشه
هي اسم فاعل مؤنث لفاعل معتل العين
لبيان غلبه هذا الجانب اللغوي والفيولوجي
وفقه اللغه في الجانب كل مرتبطا اساسا
بالاستعمار
هؤلاء المستشرقون اذا قدموا لنا خدمات
جديده عرفونا بنصوص لم نكن نعرفها ونحن
كنا في عصر الظلمات في عصر الانحطاط
وقدموا
مثلا ولم يكن في الحقيقه يهوديا ولكن على
كل حال ينتمي لهذه المدرسه
العقيده والشريعه ودرس الاحاديث النبويه
الى غير ذلك وكان هذا الاستشراق نحن الذي
نحن مدينون له
بانه كان المشكله ان المسلمين لم يفهموا
هذا الاستشراق ليس معاديا لهم بالشكل الذي
كانوا يتصوروا لماذا لان هذا الاستشراق
الكلاسيكي كان يقبل بالبوسلمات التي يقوم
عليها الفكر الاسلامي
واعطيك مثال هؤلاء كانوا يقبلون في مثلا
لكان ينقلون الحديث النبوي يكون هذا
الحديث غير صحيح او شيء من هذا القبيل
ولكن يقبلون بمبدا ان هناك حديث صحيح
وهناك حديث فعل
المبدا كم يقبلون بي كانوا يقبلون بفكره
ان القران هو كتاب من السماء وانه وحي
ولكن يختلفون ربما في ترتيب الايات وهذه
صوره مكيه هذه مدنيه هذه ايه فيها مشكل
الترتيب الى اخره وهو امر خاض فيه
المسلمون منذ قديم كتاب المصاحف
للسيجستاني في حديث طويل في هذا
المهم انه هذه ولكن هذا في سنه 77 سيتغير
سينتهي هذا استشراق سياتي مدرسه اخرى يعني
راديكاليه حقيقه وسبب متاعب كبيره للفكر
الاسلامي الحديث المهم ان هذه حركه
الهاسكيلا اليهوديه ستاتي ستاتي الى بعضهم
سيقبل بالاندماج بعضهم لن يندمج ولكن
ستاتي حادثه خطيره بعد ذلك بفتره
ستغير المعطيات لانه ما يسمى بالمشكل
المشكله اليهوديه يدن فراقها الالبانيه
يعني كان في مشكل في هؤلاء اليهود في
اوروبا
اندماج عدم اندماج هناك يهود ذهبوا
اليهوديه الليبراليه
بينما يهوديه ارثوذكسيه جديده او
ارثوذكسيه جديده للرد على هذه الحركه
الليبراليه وستعرف مسارها فيه ستاتي حادثه
تغير الامور راسا على عقب هي حديثه
هذا ضابط الفرنسي الذي ستتهمه الاوساط
المعاديه للساميه الفرنسيه بانه سبب خساره
فرنسا في الحرب
[موسيقى]
والشخص الذي سيغطي هذه المحاكمه ستبين
لاحقا ان العمليه غير صحيحه
ولكن الشخص الذي يغطى هذه المحاكمه
[موسيقى]
هذا النمساوي الذي ارسلته صحيفته ليغطي
هذه المحاكمه
واستنتج من هذه العمليه
ان انك لو خرجت من جلدك لم اعرفك كما يقول
مصنع القديم الشهير نجاح
يعني انت اليهودي لن تقبل في اوروبا مهما
فعلت
ان هذا الاندماج وهم والنتيجه بعد كل هذه
السنوات الطوال من محاولات الاندماج في
اوروبا تبين ان هذا اليهودي هو شخص غير
مرغوب فيه وستبدا حل ثالث لمشكله اليهوديه
في اوروبا هي ما ستقترحه
الحركه الصهيونيه المشروع الصهيوني
المشروع الصهيوني جاء كحل ثالث لفشل
الاندماج والانصهار
سيقول اليهود العالم ان الحل الان
ليس في الاندماج ولا هو الخروج من اوروبا
وايجاد حل للمشكله اليهوديه خارج اوروبا
وسيكتب
كتابه بالالمانيه
يوجد
ان يوضح النقطه اثارت مشاكل كبيره في
العالم العربي وفي اوروبا وادت الى كوارث
على مستوى الفهم
وتم اصلاح الخطا في الترجمات في السنوات
الاخيره
يتحدث الترجمه الحرفيه هي دوله اليهود
وليست الدوله اليهوديه
الترجمه ترجمت في البدايه الدوله يهوديه
بينما لم يكن
يبحث عن دوله يهوديه كان رجلا
مات بامراض جنسيه منقوله
كان الدافعه لمشروعه هو الصهيونيه
المسيحيه سنرى ان كل هذا الذي فكر فيه كان
الدافع اليه هو القس ويليام هتلر القصه
الذي كان موجود في السفاره البريطانيه في
النمسا وهذا امر اصبح يعني معروف لدى
المتخصصين الصهيوني المسيحيه هي التي
قدمت اكبر الدعم للمشروع الصهيوني
قبل ان يلتحق به اليهود
اليهود اوروبا في تلك الفتره كانوا رافضين
لهذا المشروع ورافضين لاي عوده الى شيء
اسمه ثوبيل بعد قليل الموضوع هذا المهم
انه تدور هرزل كان يبحث عن مكان يعيش فيه
اليهود
ولذلك المؤتمر الاول في بازل في سويسرا
حضره علمنيون ويهود اشتراكيون ينتمون الى
الى الى الى الاوساط الاشتراكيه اليهوديه
في اوروبا الشرقيه لانه كانت هي معقل هذا
التفكير وان كانت هناك افكار بدايات في
الحقيقه مع يهود القلعي للبحث عن عوده الى
فلسطين ولكن كان طيارا هامشيا وحضر فيه
اثنين من كبار الصهاينه المسيحيين من
بينهم مؤسس الصليب الاحمر
يهوديه يعني
هامشيه لا معنى لحتى انه في الحقيقه
المؤتمر وقع وقع في بازل سويسرا والمفروض
كان ان يقع في مدينه ميونخ الالمانيه ولكن
اليهود المانيا هذا المشروع وهذا الشخص
فتحول الى مدينه
لان اليهوديه كانت رافضه لفكره انشاء وطن
خارجه
اليهوديه
التقليديه الى تلك الفتره كانت رافضه راسا
على عقب اساسا كل المشروع الصهيوني
سيتم العمليه بعد ذلك سنبين للساده
المشاهدين كيف تمت هذه العمليه بطبيعه
حاله مخاطر هذا المشروع على العالم العربي
المهم انه كان يبحث عن دوله لليهود ولذلك
كانت المقترحات في البدايه ان يكون هذا
امر معروف انه الشيطان هؤلاء اليهود في
ليبيا مثلا في في اوغندا في الارجنتين لم
يكن مطروحا فكره ان يكون دوله يهوديه في
فلسطين هي دوله لليهود ونذكر الساده
المشاهدين بشيء شبيه وما وقع في الباكست
مع محمد علي جناح او محمد علي جنا محمد
علي جينا في التصوره في تفكير وهو رجل
المحامي فقد تكون الليبرالي معلما في
بريطانيا
كان يبحث اثناء انشقاقه عن المؤتمر الهندي
كان يبحث عن دوله يعيش فيها المسلمون
لم يكن يبحث عن انشاء دوله اسلاميه
وفي تصور
لانه استحال بالنسبه له رغم كل مناشدات
امهات مغاندي وانشقاق في المؤتمر الحزب
المؤتمر المهم
حل للمسلمين هو انهم يعيشون في دوله
منفصله دوله ولكن دون ان تحكم ان تكون
محكومه بالشريعه اليهوديه بالشريعه
الاسلاميه او ان تكون دوله اسلاميه
لان هذا التحول في الباكستان من دوله
للمسلمين الى دوله اسلاميه سيتحول مع مع
الجنرال ضياء الحق
بعد بعد قتل
اسمه الرئيس
سيبدا البحث عن مشروعيه للحكم وسيتم
التقرب الى هذه الجماعات الدينيه وتحويل
الباكستان شيئا فشيء من دوله للمسلمين الى
دوله اسلام يعني لو قام محمد
التي حرم قبل في الحقيقه
الغربي المهم بالنسبه
كان يبحث عن دوله يعيش فيها اليوم
كان رجلا علمانيا مستهترا بالدين
كانت حياته وعلاقته بدين ضعيفه الى اقصى
الحدود ولكن شيئا فشيئا النقاشات
ستؤدي الى مؤتمر الصهيوني الاول والثاني
والثالث الى اخره لا بدايه تغليب الحل في
فلسطين نتيجه ضغط الصهيونيه المسيحيه
ونتيجه الدعم البريطاني بطبيعه الحال التي
الذي كانت
تمارسه وستكون فلسطين تحت الانتداب تحت
الانتداب البريطاني بعد تقسيمات الى غير
ذلك
حتى انه وعد بلفور
كثير من الناس لا يعرفون ان وعد بلفور هذا
لم يكتب بالانجليزيه
النسخه الاصليه كتبت بالعبريه
وكتبها الاديب الصهيوني نحو
ولذلك النص العبري يتحدث عن يقول جيوش هوم
تحدث عن
ه الرئيس الامريكي رفض في تلك الفتره كلمه
السيد فتم الاستعاذه عنها
لانها تعريب لانها
نقل الصيغه الانجليزيه لكلمه بيت
اليهوديه
بيت يهودي
وكلمه البيت في اللغه العبريه هي مظلله
لانها تعني احيانا الدوله
فاذا هذا النص
كما قلت يعني هو جزء في مرحله لاحقه
للمشروع لتاسيس هذا المشروع الصهيوني وهذا
كتبت في الحقيقه مقال يتحدث عن عن العلاقه
التي كانت موجوده عن الصهيونيه المسيحيه
لانه جزء من الطيار التاريخيا داخل
المسيحيه
القديس اغسطين
وهو الطيار الذي يدعو الى الى الى الى
تاسيس او ان هؤلاء اليهود
يجب مساعدتهم لتاسيس وطن الى اخره لانه
جزء من المسيحيين كان يعتقد اما بضروره
اباده اليهود لانهم لم يؤمنوا بالمسيح هو
التيار اخر كان يرى ان هؤلاء اليهود يجب
ان تبقى منهم بقيه باقيه يشهد عوده المسيح
في اخر الزمان وعند عوده المسيح الى اخر
الزمان سيخيرون ضمن الدخول في الايمان
بيسوع او انتهاء ولذلك هناك مصلحه اساسيه
للصهيونيه المسيحيه الصهيونيه المسيحيه في
الدفاع عن المشروع الصهيوني لانه يجب
مساعده اليهود على العوده الى فلسطين
حتى اذا عاد يسوع في اخر الزمان سيجد
الجماعه التي عاش بينها في بدايه حياه
توفير المناخ الذي ولذلك تجد هذا هذا هذا
هذا هذا الزخم الذين يجد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وكبار مستشارين
امريكيين في المسائل الروحيه وفي
الدبلوماسيه الروحيه واخيرا مثلا فكل هذا
كل هذا السته او سبعه الذين هم يعني
بجانبه كلهم ينتهون الى هذه الصهيونيه
المسيحيه وفيهم ابن القس جري فروال
المشهور بصونيته المسيحيه الكبيره
ليش كانت موجوده ليبيا اوغندا اوغندا
والارجنتين اولا
لان كما قلت المشروع في البدايه لم يكن
مشروع ديني كان مشروعا سياسيا هو حل
لمشكله اليهود
ما كان امكانيه للاندماج
مكان امكانيه
البقاء في الجيتو
في اطار مشكله
القوميات الناشئه انذاك هناك شيء اسمه
القوميه اليهوديه ويجب حل هذه المشكله
مشكل السياسي فاذا المهم هو ليس بشرط ان
يكون هذا امر فلسطيني لانه هذا ديني ولكن
اعطيك شيء اخر لماذا رفضت اليهوديه
التقليديه او اليهوديه في ذلك الزمان هذا
المشروع لسبب بسيط
اولا هذا يحتاج الى دراسه طويله حول مفهوم
الارض
واهميه وقداسه فلسطين بالنسبه لليهود يعني
بعض خراب الهيكل الاول وخروج اليهود من من
فلسطين
من باب النكته مش النكته في الحقيقه ولكن
عندها دلاله تاريخيه انه اثناء خروج
اليهود
انحصار الرومان
للبيت المقدس
تحايل اليهود لاخراج شخصيه دينيه
هي الرب يونان
الذي اسس المشنه
هو هي روايه بيولوجيه ولكنها تعكس ككل
الميثولوجيات حقيقه معينه
ادعوا ان هذا الحاخام قد توفي وانهم
يحتاجون الى ان يدفنوه خارج المدينه فوضعه
في تابوت وطلب اذن الحاكم الروماني ليفتح
ابواب المدينه المحاصره ليدفن خارج
المدينه
وتم بهذه القريه تهريب
هذا الحاخام الذي انطلق الى مدينه الجليل
الى شمال فلسطين وفي الجليل اسس مدرسه
هي التيتولى بعد ذلك جمع نص المشنه
اليهود يعتبرون من هذه القصه ان الذي حفظ
اليهود ليس الدوله
وان الذي حفظ التاريخ اليهود تاريخيا ليس
الكيان السياسي وليس الجيش وليس القوه
العسكريه الذي حفظ اليهود هو التوراه
هو الدين
ولذلك
سيعتبرون ان هذا الامر مكون مكون اساسي
ما الذي تقوله هذه النصوص التورتيه
والتلميذيه بعد ذلك حول مفهوم الارض
اولا هناك خلاف في حدود هذه الارض
الان تبدا واين تنتهي احيانا تضيق جدا
واحيانا تتسع من الدين الى الفرات كلما
تضيق الطريق يعني في حدود الساحليه في
حدود ساحل الساحل الساحل فلسطين الان
واحيانا كثيره لا يتم التركيز على الارض
الموعوده التي وعد بها وانما التركيز تم
التركيز فقط على على القدس على بيت المقدس
فالفترات التي العوده من السبي البابلي
كان التركيز على بيت المقدس في الفترات
الخروج من هذه الاماكن يتم يرجع الحديث عن
عن الارض وارض اسرائيل الى اخره
حتى انه احدى في في بدايه في تكوين الكيان
الصهيوني في 48 كان في خلاف ما بين بن
غوريون زعيم حزب المباي وبعض بعض اليهود
المتدينين حول
مشاكل الدستور ولم يوضع دستور لاسرائيل
منذ تلك اللحظه وانما استعيد عنه بما يسمى
او الوضع الراهن يعني اسرائيل الان حوالي
15 قانون اساسي في انتظار وبدات الان
مطالبات بتاسيس دستور في هذا الخلاف
الحديث معنا تنياهو المهم ان هذه
هذه
الارض كان يقول عندما يسال ما هي حدود
اسرائيل كان يقول ان افضل مفسر لحدود
اسرائيل هو الجيش الاسرائيلي
حيثما توقف الجندي الاسرائيلي فثم تحدود
اسرائيل
يعني هذا هذا فيما يخص اليهوديه التقليديه
كانت تعتبر ان كان في نقاش داخل الفقهاء
اليهود هل سكن ارض اسرائيل واجبه ام لا
في طيار داخل الفقهاء اليهود يعتبر انه
مثل مثل ما نحن مثلا في تونس او في
الجزائر نتمنى الموت في مكه
ولكن سكنا مكه ليس واجب او البقاء او
المكوث هناك طيار داخل اليهودي يعتبر انه
ليس واجبا
هي مدينه مقدسه ولكن ليس من الواجب ان
نذهب ان نذهب اليه
هناك طيار اخر في فترات معينه كانت تاتي
جماعات
لاداء الشعار او لطلب انه ينسى يفضل انه
يموت في تلك الاراضي المقدسه ولكن في نقاش
اخر في القرن اني هل يجوز او هل يجب دخول
هذه الارض بالقوه المسلحه بالقوه
اليهود في نص شهير اسمه نص يتحدث عن
العهود
يتسمى بالعبريه او العهود الثلاث من بينها
الحديث هذا تمسك كثير من علماء اليهود
والقانون التاسع عشر وهو الذي يمنع اليهود
من العوده الى فلسطين باستعمال القوه
بالمفاوضه بشراء الارض بطرق سلميه الى
اخره ولكن دون استعمال القوه المسلحه
الحركه الصهيونيه
لن تذهب هذا المذهب
سترى انه يجب التسريع مساعده الاله
مساعدته على العوده
العوده بالشراء الاراضي ولكن ايضا بشترن
وكل هذه المنظمات التي ستسخرها الحركه
الصهيونيه للدخول الى فلسطين وسياسه
الدوليه وبريطانيا والمفاوضات والبيع
والشراء الى غير
واستعمال القوه العسكريه هذا خلاف الحركه
الصينيه ما عدا التصور الديني التقليدي
واذا هذا الشعب اذا انه حركه
هو هو ايجاد موضع قدم في فلسطين
بالتاسيس الصندوق القومي
الصهيوني كمنحيه ماليه لشراء الاراضي
استعمل الدبلوماسيه عن طريق البريطانيين
مثلا
او الرئيس المؤتمر سعودي يظل دوله دوله
اسرائيل فيما تذكر
وهو الذي اسس باسمه معهد التخيليون لانه
في اسرائيل معهد التقنيه الذي كان مسؤول
عن صناعه القمر النوويه يعود الى هذا
الرجل الذي كان عالم فيزياء عالم كيمياء
في الحقيقه وهو الذي ساعد البريطانيين في
حل بعض مشاكل الطاقه اثناء الحرب الحرب مع
الدوله الدوله العثمانيه وفي في
الامبراطوريتها في الهند الى غير ذلك
وكوفي وكوفي يقال انه احدى الاشياء التي
كفئ بها وهذا هذا الوعد وعد بلفور في 1917
علما وانه على كل حال هذا الموضوع للتاريخ
انه فيه من العرب من قبل بفكره ان هذه
الدوله قد تكون يهوديه الى غير ذلك ولكن
هذا بشكل في مرحله في مرحله متاخر المهم
انه هذه الصهيونيه كما قلت هي حركه
معلمه ضعيفه الصيله بالدين شيئا فشيئا
شيئا فشيئا
شيئا
سيزداد الى ان يصل الى الذروه اليوم
فالبدايه كان في امر في البدايه جدا ضعيف
جدا المشروع الصهيوني في البدايه هو مشروع
الصهيونيه المسيحي
وهو ايضا مشروع عدد من اليهود الذين
اعتبروا ان الحل للمشكله اليهوديه هو في
اطار القوميات حل المشكله القوميه بالخروج
عن اوروبا والبحث عن مكان ستؤدي الاحداث
شيئا فشيئا الى الدخول الى الى القبول
بفلسطين اولا فلسطين كارض وايضا اللغه
العبريه لانه طرح كثيرا ان اللغه لغه هذا
الوطن الجديد ما الذي ماذا ستكون كان
المطروح اللغه الالمانيه هي اللغه اللغه
القويه في ذلك ولغه النخبه الى اخره وفي
مصر مرحله ثانيه تم اقتراح اللغه ليديشيه
هي لغه يهود بولونيا وشرق اوروبا بشكل عام
وهي رطانا من مزيج من البولونيه والعبريه
والالمانيه وفيها مسرح شهير ومسرح جيد
حقيقه ولكن سيؤدي الخلافات النقاش عفوا
الى انتصار التيار الذي سيقول ما يسمى
الطيار احياء اللغه العبريه
والذي سيقول
بن ابي عازر واحد كبار الذين وضعوا وضعوا
المعجم العبري الحديث اذا هذا هذا مسار
ستاخذ شيئا فشيئا سيؤدي هذا الى الى الى
الدخول الى فلسطين شيئا فشيئا الوحيد الذي
انتبه من العرب الى ان امرا ما يحدث غير
طبيعي هو نجيب العزوري
كبار مثقفين السوريين كتب بالفرنسيه
قال ان هذه الموجات موجات الهجره التي
تاتي الى فلسطين هي موجات غير عاديه
ليست غايه ولا الحج ولا زياره الاماكن
المقدسه وانما هذا امر منظم ويسير بوتيره
منظمه وينظر بوخيم الهواء
سيدرك العرب شيئا فشيئا بعد بعد بعد بعد
وعد بلفور ان الامر فعلا فعلا يعني يبعث
على خطوره كبيره وستزداد حركات الهجره
وستزداد مع الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ومحاوله اوروبا التكفير عن ذنوبها التي
قامت بانزيه بايجاد حلها وستاتي موجات
كثيره في 48
في 48
قلت انه
سيجد حل المشكله الدينيه الاستبعاد
المتدينين لان هؤلاء المتدينين الذين
كانوا منخرطين فيما يسمى
لم تكن لهم مطالب سياسيه كبيره كانوا
يطالبون بان تكون هذه الدوله اولا لا يجب
ان يكون هناك دستور ينص على ان غير
التوراه هو هو الذي يقود الدوله
ولذلك السبب
تفاهمات الوضع القائم الوضع الراهن كان
ذكيا كان يسبب الثعلب
اراد ان يتجنب مواضع الخلاف
فقبل بتنازلات ما هي هذه التنازل اولا
اعطاء كل ما يتعلق بالمسائل الاحوال
الشخصيه تنزل فيه لليهود التقليدي اليهود
اليهود اليهود هؤلاء اليهود التقليديين
اللي كانوا رافضين
لا هذا الجزء الذي بدا قبل بمشروعه والعيش
في هذا المشروع
اعطاهم الاحوال الشخصيه وجعل الحاخاميه
الكبرى في اسرائيل اليوم في مشكل كبير من
هو اليهودي
هذا موضوع موضوع قديم ولكن قبل بالتعريف
التي الذي تقوم به هذه الحاخاميه او هذه
اليهوديه التقليديه اليهودي هو الذي من ام
يهودي الى اخره
في الاحوال الشخصيه الزواج والطلاق
والبراط الاخير هي في جزء منه محكوم بهذه
الشريعه اليهوديه انه في اسرائيل كان
عندهم كانوا من اراد ان يتزوج على خلاف
الشريعه اليهوديه عليهم يذهب الى قبرص او
الى مكان اخر للتزاوج ثم يعود الى سرير
ليتم اعتراف بزواج قبل الاصلاحات التي
قامت بها الى غير ذلك
الزواج مدني زواج مدني على غير الصياغ
الدينيه مثلا هو موجود في كثير من الدول
ليس بحضور حامله وفي قوانين وتم اذا
قوانين الارث الى اخره
تكون بحسب القوانين اليهوديه وقع تغيير
بعد ذلك في اسرائيل في القوانين الارث
فيما يخص المساواه لانه القوانين الارث
تمنع المراه في اليهوديه قوانين المتعلقه
بالمره قوانين المتخلفه جدا يعني
كثير منصب على العالم الاسلامي ولكن
الوضعيه المراه في في التقليديه اليهوديه
في اسرائيل وضع سيء جدا المهم هذا في
البدايه على كل حال
متعلق بالاحوال الشخصيه فيما يتعلق
بالكشروط يعني في يتعلق بالاكل الحلال
والحرام من الكاشير وغير كاشير كل
وقبل انهم ان هؤلاء اليهود لا يقومون
بالخدمه العسكريه
العكس ما هو موجود اليوم لان الوحدات
النخبه في الجيش وفي اسرائيل هي وحدات
متاتيه من الاوساط الدينيه
تغير الامور ولكن في البدايات كانوا
يعتبرون تصور التقليدي كان يقول كما قلت
منذ قليل انه الضامن
لبقاء اليهود في العالم ليس الدوله وليس
الجيش هو التوراه فهؤلاء يخدمون التوراه
ويقراون التوراه وهذه اكبر خدمه يقدمونها
لشعب اسرائيل فتم اعفائهم من الخدمه
العسليه رغم بعد ذلك اوساط اخرى يساريه
ومعلمه
اذا كما قلت اذن الخدمه وايضا تمويل
المدارس الدينيه والجماعات كانوا يريدون
اموال من هذه وتركوا له باب السياسه
الخارجيه والحكم هذه المفاهمه التي كانت
بين بين اكودات اسرائيل وبين حزب بين حزب
بين بين بن جريون في حزم حزب المطاي
واستمرت هذه المفاهمات الى الى حدود 67
الحدود 67 ستبدا الامور تتغير شيئا
لماذا تغيرت في 67 لانه في 67 كما كما
تعلم
ولكن بالنسبه اليهود لم تكن نفسها كان
تدخل الاله في التاريخ
في 67
سيتم توحيد القدس
الشرقيه والغربيه احتلالها
وستحقق اسرائيل انتصارات باهره في خمسه
ايام وفي سته ايام
وتنتصر على الجيوش عربيه كثيره
كان ينظر الى هذا الحدث لجلال على انه
تدخل للذات الالهيه الى اسرائيل في شعب في
مسار التاريخ
وستبدا في اسرائيل موجه كبيره من التدين
مثل ما بدات ايضا الموجه
المتدينون في العالم العربي راوا في ذلك
عقوبه اليه
ما اصابنا هو لاننا ابتعدنا عن الاسلام
وكل ان تعرف الصراع المكان موجود بين عبد
الناصر والاخوان الى غير ذلك
العالم العربي في ان الحل ليس في
الاشتراكيه ولا في القوميه وانما الاسلام
هو الحل ستكتب كتاب كتب في الاسلام هو
الحال بينما في اسرائيل ستبدا ما يسمى
بالعبريه يعني الصح والديني
وسيبدا اليهود يدخلون في دين في اليهوديه
افواجا حتى من كان لم يكن متدينا سيصاب
بهذه
الحميه الدينيه وستبدا موجه من التداول
التدين ساهم فيها
انتصار تيار
كان يسير برفق
مع الحركه الصهيونيه يراسه حخام وانا ادعو
كل المهتمين في العالم العربي وفي
الجامعاتبوا بهذا الرجل هذه المدرسه لان
هي
كان يقودها من ناحيه الفكريه والروحيه
يهودي
من اوروبا شرقيه هجوله المتحده الامريكيه
ثم عاد الى فلسطين وكان هو كان هو حاخام
حاخام فلسطين هو الربي
ابراهيم
الرب كوك هذا شخصيه صوفيه فيلسوف متدين
وكان ينظر بعين كان يضحك في قراره نفسه من
هذه الصهيونيه التي ترى نفسها حركه
علمانيه
وقال
يعني هو وجد الحل
في التوفيق بين الصهيونيه واليهوديه
قال ان هؤلاء بشكل مختصر
هؤلاء الصهاينه العلمانيون يتصورون انهم
بفعل هذا يحققون اهدافا بشريه
دنيويه في الحقيقه هم
يقومون ينخرطون في مسار الهي
وانهم يتصورون انهم يفعلون اشياء
يا دنيويه ولكنهم هم يفعلون هم ينخرطون
فيما تطلوا يطلبه الى اسرائيل
وانه لا تنافيا بين الصهيونيه
وبين هؤلاء
بين اليهوديه وهؤلاء الصهاينه لان هؤلاء
الصهاينه هم الخدم الذين ارسلهم اله
اسرائيل وان لم يشعروا لخدمه مشروعه في
العوده في فلسطين وكتب مقالات صوفيه
ودينيه وفلسفيه ووجد اليهود جزء كبير من
اليهود ظلتهم في هذه الشخص
هذه اللحظه هو بدا في 35 موجود عاش في
فلسطين في 35 ولكن تياره سيصبح سيجد فيه
اليهود ملاغا لهذه الماساه او التناقض بين
الصهيونيه وبين وبين وبين وبين الدين
حتى كبار الجنرالات وكبار العسكريين عندما
اقرا المذكرات يقولون ان كانوا ينتمون الى
هذا الى هذا التيار وهذا التيار سيتواصل
في اسرائيل عن طريق ابنه
الذاكره يظل هو اسحاق
هذا هذا الابن هو الذي بعد 67
ستقوم مدرسته بتفريخ
تفريخ
كل اللوثات التي ستصيب الصهيونيه
المعاديه للعرب بشكل مطلق
سابين
كانت في اسرائيل مدرسه تتسمى
مركاز هراف او مركز الرب راضيا ولقب تشريف
لهذا الرب الكبير كوك والتي اهتم بها ابنه
ووظيفتها هي كما نقول هي كليه للشريعه
من اكبر الكليات في الشريعه وهي التي كونت
الاف المؤلفه من المستوطنين
هذه المدرسه هي التي اخرجت لنا
حركه كتله الايمان وهي التي اخرجت لنا
هناك احد كبار
الارهابيين
يجب ان يرحلوا من هنا
وكل هذه الحركات التي نعرفها اليوم من
المستوطنين وبكل التسميات
حي كلها خرجت من رحم هذه المدرسه الدينيه
وبدات وبدات بعد 67 في مشروع استيطان
سيتم اعتراضها احيانا من قبل البعض
اليساريين ولكن
الاحداث بينت انه في 67 ثم في 77 يعني بعد
الرجوع اليمين بعد انهيار اليسار في
اسرائيل ورجوع ورجوع حزب حيروت رجوع
مناحين بيجن اللي هو قومي ينتمي الى
الصهيونيه القوميه
التي اسسها فلاديمير جابوتينسكي الروسي
اللي عنده مقال في سنه 1933 بعنوان
الجدار الحديدي
والذي سجل الحديد يعني الجدار الحديدي في
التفكير جابوتينسكي هو التالي جمله بسيطه
يقول لو كنت فلسطينيا لرفضت هذا المشروع
الفلسطينيين الحق هذه ارضهم ونحن دخلناها
وسندخلها عنوه وكنت فلسطينيا
الحل هو يجب ان لا نقتل رغبه المقاومه
نقتل المقاومه في الفلسطينيه قتل
الفلسطيني الامر منتظر وعادي
يجب ان يفكر الصهيوني بطريقه يجب ان نقتل
في الفلسطيني ليس المقاومه وانما الرغبه
في المقاومه التفكير في المقاومه مجرد
التفكير يجب ان ينعدم وهذا هو ما يسميه
الجدار الحديثي
هذا الجدار الفكري
سيبنيه ريال شارون عمليا بمقتضى بعقليه
الجدار الاسمنت الى غير ذلك واحد كبار
المؤرخين الجنود الاسرائيليين المناهض
شيئا مائل الصهيونيه افيشاين كتب كتابا
بهذا المعنى الجدار الجدار الجدار الحديدي
اذا
هذه هي كانت
في 67 والتحولت بعد التقاء هذا اليمين
الديني
اللي هو منحدر من الصهيونيه الدينيه
بالتيار القومي الذي اتي من جيبوتي سيتم
الالتحاق
ومنذ ذلك التاريخ سيصبح في اسرائيل ما
اسميه
بالكوكتيل القاتل
عندما تلتقي القوميه الشوفينيه
باشد التيارات الدينيه مغاليه وتعصبا وله
نتيجه لحركه هذه الصهوه الدينيه بطبيعه
الحال سيصيب الفلسطينيين ويصيب العرب شر
المستطير من هذه الخلطه
الخلطه المدمره
هؤلاء المتدينون سينطلقون في مشروع كبير
هو اسمه اسرائيل هشلم
يعني اسرائيل الكامله
يجب استيطان كل ارض اسرائيل
وما هي ارض اسرائيل اللي هي لحد الان على
كل بالتفسير الموجود لان هي بحدودها
الحاليه يجب ترك اي موضع في فلسطين
في كل فلسطين كل فلسطين بالتصور القانوني
القائمه الان لم يتخلوا في ادابيتهم
الداخليه عن اسرائيل الكبرى ومن من كلاه
من هذا يكتب ولكن عمليا هذه الارض لانه
بعد 48 ما الذي واقع
في عرب الخط الاخضر في منطقه اللي هي خط
الهدنه بقي هناك فلسطينيون يعيشون
في هذه الدوله الجديده ولهم الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه بمقتضى القانون ولكنهم
فلسطينيون ويقول يقول كهانه عن هؤلاء يقول
هؤلاء يجب ان يفهم في خطاب مر الوحيده
الذي ظهر دخل فيها الكنيست ثم بعد تم تم
مطاردته وقتل في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قتل في نيويورك وهو كان عميل
مزدوج في الحقيقه مع الاثبياء يخدم ولكن
ايضا متطرف صهيوني متطرف عمل خطاب من اروع
ما يمكن ان يستمع اليه مواطن عربي وانا
الاستماع الى هذا القطار يقول انتم يا
اعضاء الكنيست
انتم احميره بهذه العباره
لماذا انتم احميره انتم تشبهون
غلامي ابراهيم عندما حمل ابنه اسحاق
ليذبحه
ابراهيم وهو يحمل اسحاق ليذبحه حسب التصور
اليهودي نظر الى غلامين وقال لهما هل ترى
يعني ما ارى
كان يقصد المذبح الذي سيذبح فيه العبريه
فاجاب نحن قال نحن لا نرى شيء قال اذا
ابقي مع الحمار هنا ساذهب انا بل انتم
لاعضاء الكنيست مثل هؤلاء مثل هذين
الغلامين احمرا لماذا انتم احمره لانكم لا
ترون ما ارى
هذا الفلسطيني الذي يعيش بيننا
تتصورون انه بتوفير الماء والكهرباء
والتعليم سيصبح اسرائيلي جيد هذا لن يصبح
ابدا اسرائيلي
لانه في اليوم الذي نحتفل فيه نحن بحاجه
بعيد الاستقلال هو يبكي النكبه
وفي اللحظه التي نتحدث فيها نحن وننشد
النشيد الاسرائيلي الامل
الذي يفرح به العرب احيانا في بعض المدن
ولا يفهمون النشيد ولا كلمات ولا تاريخ
يقول ان هؤلاء الفلسطينيين يغنون نشيد
موطني
وبدا يعدد في الحالات التي تمنع هذا
الفلسطينيين من ان يكون مواطنا اسرائيليا
جيدا انتم احمره الحل الفلسطيني الجيد
والفلسطيني المقتول او الفلسطيني الذي
يهجر يعني او حل ما يسمى بحل الترانسفير
او حل التهجير القسري للفلسطينيين يجب
اخراج هؤلاء الفلسطينيين من ارض اسرائيل
بحيث بحيث هذه هي هذه العقليه اذا استيطان
ارض اسرائيل كلها وهذه العمليه المتسارعه
منذ 67 باشكال بوتائر مختلفه الى اليوم
ادت عمليا الى انتهاء شيء اسمه حل
الدولتين
يعني نوضح للساده المشاهدين ما معنى حل
وربما دارت نافعه سابين يعني انا واياك
نتفاوض حول اقتساب علبه من الجبن فيها
ثمانيه قطع
واثناء هذا الحوار ونحن نتحدث في كيفيه
ايجاد حل هذه انا التهم في كل مره قطعه
كنا نتحدث عن ثماني قطاع فوجدنا في
النهايه اننا بحكم هذا الاستيطان ما في
ولا قطعه واحده انتهى حل الدولتين
ولهذا السبب الان بعض الاوساط الامريكيه
منذ منذ اسابيع قليله مهمه جدا في في
جريده فرن افرس تتحدث عن عوده الحديث عن
حل الدوله الوحيده
الذي كان مرفوض من كل من كل
الاوساط الصهيونيه والبعض الاوساط
الصهيونيه صارت تحذر اذا رفضنا حل
الدولتين سنقع في حل في حل في ورطه وهي حل
الدوله الواحده الدوله الواحده فيها مشكل
اولا
هي الان نحن الان موصوبون باننا دوله
ابرتين
وهذا اكثر ما يقلق وحركه المقاطعه البي دي
اس المشهوره حول العالم تحاول ان تركز على
ان هذا النظام هو نظام ابارت هيد يعني
يقوم بميز عنصري داخل اتحدث عن عن غزه او
عن
الضفه ولكن عن عرب ثمانيه عرب ثمانيه
واربعين اذا هذا هذا نظام ابارتيد واخطر
من هذا النمو الديموغرافي
لا يضمن او سيضمن في المستقبل تفوق العددي
لي وهناك حديث محموم عن شيء اسمه دوله
يهوديه لانهم يريدونها دوله يهوديه
وحل الدوله الواحديه يمنع من ان تكون هذه
الدوله دوله يهوديه لان بهذا المنطق
يريدون التسويق لدوله يهوديه وديمقراطيه
اذا هي ولكنها لا يمكن ان تكون الا يهوديه
مع العرب الديمقراطيه مع اليهود
واليهوديه مع العرب
وهذا هذا مازق هذه الدوله ولهذا ولهذا
يعني هناك الحل هو بيان هذه التناقضات في
هذه في هذه ولكن العوده الان الى موضوع
الدوله الواحده ليس هو كما ترى كما طرح في
ميثاق منظمه التحرير او في ادبيات الحاله
الوطنيه في زمن زمن قديم للامور تغيرت على
الارض الى غير ذلك وتطرح تطرح مشاكل معقده
ولكن على كل حال مهم جدا ان الاوساط
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه وبعضها واوساط
نافذه في التحديد السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه اصبحت تتحدث عن حل حل الدوله حل
الدوله حل الدوله الواحده والعوده الى حل
الدوله الواحده
[موسيقى]
سيضع اسرائيل امام تناقضاتها
لا يمكن ان تكون دوله يهوديه
يعني
منذ الى انتزاع فكره ان هذه الدوله يهوديه
تضرعوا بان بان بان وعد بلفور تحدث عن
جويشهو
وتضرعوا بالعلاقات العربيه الاعتراف
الاخير بين الدوله يهوديه مثل ما هناك
الدول الاسلاميه ويحاولون البحث عن
امكانيات كثيره لاقصاء لاخراج هذا
الفلسطيني من هذه من هذه الارض ولكن على
كل حال
اعتقد ان الامور ستسير بطريقه معقده
بالنسبه الى اسرائيل في السنوات القادمه
اذا احسن الفلسطينيون بطبيعه الحال واحسن
العرب التعامل مع هذا مع هذا الموضوع ومن
هذه الدوله بكيفيه وعن معرفه انا حدثتك
منذ في البدايه عن مثل المخاطر
هذه الدوله تسعى منذ البدايات المشروع
الصهيوني في جوهره
يسعى الى الى جعل اسرائيل جسم طبيعي في
المنطقه هذا هو حلم الحركه الصهيونيه يجب
ان يقبل الانسان العربي
في فلسطين ولكن من المحيط الى الخليج بان
هذا الجسم هو جسم طبيعي
ولذلك تسعى الى الى حركه مستمره من
محاولات التطبيع مع سياسي ولكن التطبيع
السياسي في الحقيقه
اتفهم ان يكون لبعض لبعض الانظمه السياسيه
مرونه في الحركه والتصرف
لانه اكراهات رجل السياسه هي غير اكراهات
المثقف
ورجل الفكر
والانسان العادي
وعلاقات السياسيه دائما متقلبه وايله الى
الزاويه الاحيان
والاتفاق الذي يمضي اليوم قد يتغير غدا
الخوف كل الخوف هو
ان يتسرب هذا التطبيع الى داخل المجتمع
يصبح جزء من حياه المواطن العربي في حياته
الاجتماعيه في مؤسسته في جامعاته في شركته
في اكله في شرب يده هذا ما يجب الانتباه
اليه
الاتفاقيات الابراهيميه مثلا اعطيك مثال
الابراهيميه لا نتحدث عن جوانب السياسيه
والجوانب الاقتصاديه فلها متخصصون يفهمون
في هذا
وفي الحقيقه ليس الغايه من كلام هذا هو
انما تعريض باي نظام او باي ولكن سابين
المغالطات الفكريه في هذا الموضوع
والمغالطات الدينيه بالاساس الخطيره انا
بينت في دراسه قلت
انه اتفاقيه الابراهيميه تريد ان تركز على
هذا الجد المشترك
ابراهيم ولا تسميه ابراهيم
الابراهيمي نسبه الى ابرهه يعني هي منذ
البدايه تاخذ التسميه التوراتيه
وجوهر هذه الاتفاقيات الابراهيميه هو
القول بانه بملل ننتمي الى جد واحد
فلا باس بان تقاسم خيارات المنطقه مع
بعضنا البعض
يعني انا كاسرائيل عندي حق في البترول
السعودي وفي النفط الاماراتي وفي الغاز
القطري او في البترول الاسود
نحن ابناء ابراهيم
ولكن ما يتم تناسيه المغالطه هو انها حيله
من ابرهام ليتحايل على ابراهيم
كيف
لان ابراهيم الذي تحدث عنه ليس هو ابراهيم
ولا كنت بينت الحديث منذ البدايه ابراهيم
التوراتي الذي يحتاجون به في ملكيه ارض
فلسطين باعتبار ان هذا الميراث هو ميراث
اسحاق واسحاق من ابراهيم هو ليس ابراهيم
الذي نؤمن به
ولهذا كل ما يتعلق بشجره النبوه
وابراهيميه وصوره ابراهيم والحديث عن
التوراه التي قالت
رفضنا تصورهم للتوراه ورفضنا التصورهم
الابراهيم والتصورهم باسحاق والتصوره
لاسماعيل وكل هذه وكل هذه الامور
اذا هناك محاوله للتلبيس
باعتبار ان هذا ابراهيم هو اب الجميع وجد
الجميع لا يا سيدي ابراهيم ابراهيمكم ليس
ابراهيم هنا
وتوراتكم ليست هي ثوراتنا
وقص على ذلك
وفي العهد
وفي كل هذه الامور
فهناك محاوله تلبيس هذا هذا مشروع ما يسمى
داخل
محاوله استثمار الجوانب الروحيه والدينيه
لتمرير مشاريع سياسيه بالاساس تمكن
للمشروع الصهيوني في
هذا يجب ان نكون على بينه من هذه الامور
يجب على صاحب القرار وعلى المثقف وعلى
الاكاديميه وعلى جميع ان يفهم الخطوره هذا
الامر
يجب العمل على ان لا تكون اسرائيل جسم
طبيعي في المنطقه الى ان تؤمن بالحقوق
الكامله للشعب الفلسطيني وحل القضايا
الاربعه التي اعطيك مثال مؤتمر مدريد مثلا
قال انه
تم الحديث عن حلول وقتيه سياسيه وسلطه الى
اخره ولكن قال انه في اربعه اربع قضايا
سما قضايا الحل النهائي اللي هي القدس
والاستيطان واللاجئين وطبيعه الدوله الى
اخره واعطى خمس سنوات لحل هذه القضايا
اسحاق سمير في تلك الفتره قال سنتركهم
بعشرين سنه
يسيرون وراء هذه الان تجاوزنا العشرين سنه
ولم تحل القدس
ولا اللاجئين ولا الاستيطان الى غير
اذا عندما نقول هذا الكلام نحن لسنا طلاب
نزاع ولكن اصحاب حقوق
ويجب ان تحل هذه الحقوق باحترام حقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني في تقرير مصيره وبمقت
واعتراف بكل ما قدمته القوانين والمواثيق
الدوليه في حل التي لم تنفذ من اسرائيل
ولا ولا سطر واحد بل يقوم داني دانون برفع
التوراه ويقول نحن نملك هذه الارض بمقطع
هذه النصوص الثوره
فمن العيب اذا ان نفرد في كل هذه الحقوق
باسم يعني لم يعد الحديث عن ارض مقابل
سلامه اصبح الحديث عن سلام مقابل سلام
اتركوا هذا الامر الارض الذي امر انتهى
فهذا الجزء على كل حال من
مما
يعني نظري او دراسه لتاريخ الحركه السوريه
تجعلني يعني في حذر في الحقيقه من هذا
المشروع ليس فقط على فلسطين وانما على كل
البلاد العربيه لانه خطر هذا المشروع
يتجاوز يتجاوز المنطقه الصغيره منطقه
فلسطين ويجب يجب ان تؤسس مراكز بحث
واقسام تخصصيه
من اجل تكوين جيل جديد من الباحثين العرب
ولا يمكن ان تقوم بهذا المشروع الا دوله
او مؤسسات قويه ونافذه لها قدره لتكوين
مكتبات لست مطالبين للاعتراف
بالفلوس اليهم
نستطيع نحن نعرف ماذا ينتجون وماذا يكتبون
تستطيعون ونحصل على كل الكتابات ولكل
المقالات وكل الدراسات ونشتغل ونتعلم
اللغات
ونقوم بتاسيس بتكوين جيل من الباحثين
الذين
يساعدوننا على على تبين الطريق عندما
يختلط الخيط الابيض بالخيط
الاسود في السياسه والاقتصاد والتعليم
كل الدول العربيه كيف بيكون شكل
والله اتمنى الا تتبع كل الدولار هذا
ولكن كما قلت قليلا قلت انه للسياسه
اكراهات
ومنذ القديم تحدث عن العالم والسياسي
والمصريون مثلا طبعوا والاردنيون طبعوا
ولكن نعرف انه عندما تكون دوله قويه
والاجهزه قويه فانها التطبيع مع مصر مع
الاردن بقي في حدود بقي باردا وفي حدود
في حدود سياسيه ومراقبه ومتابعه وحتى
المركز الثقافي الاسرائيلي في القاهره
يعني
لم يعمر طويلا
وهو يكد يكون السلام بروتوكولي اكثر منه
الا خوفي ليس ليس هذا الجانب خوفي هو ان
يتسرب هذا المجتمع
اخطر انواع التطبيع هو ان تصبح اسرائيل
فيما اكلك ومشربك وكتابك وسوقك وجمعتك
وشركتك الى غير ذلك فهذا هذا هو هذا هو
هذا هو الخطير لانه اذا ارادوا العيش
بيننا فليعيشوا معنا بسلام وباحترام حقوق
الشعب الفلسطيني كامله
طب فيه شيء تقول لا يجب اعطاء اسرائيل اي
تنازل دون مقابل هذا يستدعي الوقوف الوقوف
في وجه التحول اسرائيلي الى دوله يهوديه
بكل وسائل
اذا اليوم هي
100 دوله يهوديه
كيف نقدر نصف اسرائيل شوف الدين
انا قمت بدراسه سابقه حول الدين والدوله
في اسرائيل
كما اسسها الاوائل من الجيل الاول لم تكن
دوله دينيه ولكنها تسير بخطاه متسارعه نحو
الدوله الدينيه
من يحكم اسرائيل اليوم
من هي الشخصيات السياسيه في الحكومه لم لم
يكن لليمين الديني
اي دور في الحياه السياسيه وبدا هذا الدور
بالتنامي منذ 77 منذ 67 الى ان وصل هذا
التيار الصهيوني الديني الى سده الحكم
من هو بن جرير
الان وزير الامن هو من كبار زعماء صهيونيه
الصهيونيه الدينيه من هو هذا هذا الذي
يسمى
وزير الماليه
حول الحل الحل يجب الحل القضيه الفلسطينيه
بالتوجه الى اليمين اليمين الديني وهو
الذي خطب في الكنيست
في نص فيه الموقف شهير ويقول ان اكبر خطا
ارتكباه بين غوريون
هو انه لم يكمل المهمه كما ينبغي
لو انجريون قضاء على كل الفلسطينيين في 48
قبل الهدنه لما عشنا هذه المشاكل اذا يجب
انهاء المهمه
ونحن لا نقرا لا نهتم لا نسمع
الفلسطيني يعني هو الشوكه التي بقيت
ارادها التاريخ ربما
ارادها العنايه الالهيه ليبقى في شوكه
شوكه في حلق هذه الدوله يجب التخلص
مشكلتنا فيها بشكل سريع مشكلتنا في هذا
الفلسطيني الذي بقي في هذه الارض
وتركه لو انه
قام بعمل التنظيف
لكن هذا التيار الصهيوني والان في قلب
الحكم ليس فقط في قلب الحكم هو دوره هو
حجمه الحقيقي لا يتجاوز 15% من الشعب
الاسرائيلي
اعداديه ولكنه من حيث الوزن السياسي هو
وزن رهيب جدا لماذا
لان النظام الانتخابي الاسرائيلي قايم على
النسبيه
ويجعل من المستحيل لاي حزب سياسي يعني حزب
العمل الاكبر الاحزاب الاسرائيلي هي حزب
العمل وحزب الليكود
ان يصل الى الى الى الى اغلبيه مطلق ان
يحكم بمفرده بشكل مريح دائما العاده يحكم
بوحده وخمسين في المئه
احيانا ولا يستطيع ان يحقق هذه نسبه ضئيله
الا بماذا الا بالتعاون مع الاحزاب الديني
بطلب ود الاحزاب الديني هذه وان كان عددها
صغير عدديا الا انه تاثيرها الانتخابي
والسياسي كبير جدا
وتطلب مقابل الدخول في هذه الحكومات
بتنازلات وبسياسات استيطان وبقروض وبداخله
وتهدد في كل مره بالخروج من الحكومه
واسقاط الحكومات الى غير ذلك
ويتودد زعماء اسرائيل الى هذه الجماعات
الدينيه
سواء المتحده الامريكيه او في داخل داخل
اسرائيل للحصول على وده للحصول على هذه
الاغلبيه لتمكنها ولذلك الان هو نتنياهو
هو بطبعه مناض للحقوق الفلسطينيه ولكنه
تحت رحمه هذه الجماعات
يعني مثلا
اقرب اقرب صفقه قام بها هو انه لما لما
كثرت المعارضه حول التغييرات لانه يريد ان
يمسك بالسلطه القضائيه في في اسرائيل قام
بتنازل تحت هذا الضغط الضغط الكبير
فطلب مقابل لهذا
عدم الخروج من الحكومه حتى لا تسقط
المقابل هو يمضي على تاسيس حرس وطني او
وقومي في اسرائيل وظيفته الاساسيه هي
مطارده الفلسطيني
يعني عمليه معقده
اضافه الى ان المجتمع الاسرائيلي يميل
فكريه الان الى هذه الرؤيه الدينيه ويرى
ان هؤلاء الفلسطينيين هم عب الى اخره طبعا
هناك فلسطين يقبلون جزء بسيط ككل
المجتمعات التي عرفت الاستعمار يقبلون
بهذه اللعبه ولكن بطبيعه الحال هذا كله
منافي لحقوق الفلسطينيين
الداخل وايضا الفلسطينيين الخارج بطبيعته
اذا هذول 15% ما هي المكونات الباقيه
اما يسريون او قوميون لانه فيه فم في
ثلاثه عائلات في الحقيقه هي عائلات
الصهيونيه القوميه اللي هي الحزب الليكود
واليود حزب حيروت الى اخره بمختلف
التياراتهم بطبيعه الحال واحزابهم
والتيارات الدينيه بمختلف انواعها من
الاكثر تشددا الى الاقل تشددا لانه حركه
دينيه انواع واشكال شيء اليهود
وهذا حزب شاس وهذا حزب الى اخره وتتم
عمليه تشابك ثم انفصال وتتكون تسميه جديده
وهناك بطبيعه الحال الاحزاب اليسريه التي
التي تضعف
تضعف شيئا فشيء ولم يعد لها دور حقيقي في
صنع السياسه الاسرائيلي لانه كما قلت انه
السياسه الاسرائيليه تسير الان نحو
اندماجا القوميه الدين وهذا اكبر خطر و
ضعف ضعف ضعف اليسار
اذا
على العالم العربي ان يساعد فلسطينيين
الداخل ولو انهم يحملون الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه فهم فلسطينيون يحاول ان يفك
عنهم هذه العزله ان يتعامل معهم والا
يتعامل مع اسرائيليين الا ما ثبت اسرائيل
انهم مناهضون الصهيونيه وقدموا خدمات
جليله في مناظره اسرائيل والدفاع عن الحق
الفلسطيني هذا امر محمود ويجب هناك جزء من
المؤرخين مثلا الذين رفضوا هذه السرديه
الرسميه الاسرائيليه واقتربوا كثيرا من
السرديه السرديه الفلسطينيه التي حتى حدث
عنها مؤرخون فلسطينيون كبارا نور مصالحه
الخالدي وليد الخالدي وغيرها من
الفلسطينيين وان كانوا على كل حال يتحدثون
فيهم فيهم جزء من هذه الثقافه الصهيونيه
ولكن على كل حال يجب مساعده كل من يمدد
بهذا بهذا الاحتلال وبهذه الطريقه في
التسيير الصراع العربي الاسرائيلي بكل بكل
بكل تمييز في الحقيقه بين هذا وذاك شكرا
جزيلا شكرا يا سيدي بارك الله فيك وشكرا
للمستمعين شكرا لكم وشكرا لايمن الحمادي
في اعداد الحلقه وعبد الرحمن عبود في
التصوير وعبد المجيد العطاس في التلوين
ومحمد الحسن في الهندسه الصوتيه والتحرير
هذه الحلقه محمد نور تمت اداره التواصل
الاجتماعي نوره السبيعي وفي اداره تحرير
البرنامج اسيل عبد الله هذا فنجان احد
منتجات شركه ثمانيه للنشر والتوزيع ننشر
كل الانتاج في حب من مدينه الرياض الاسبوع
المقبل القاك
[موسيقى]
طيب عمل واشتغال عبد الهام مسيري في
الموسوعه وغيره الدكتور المسيري قام بعمل
ضخم
وسد فراغا كبيرا وبالمناسبه انا
هذا المشروع مشروع المسيري في البدايه
انفقت عليه المملكه العربيه السعوديه كثير
من الناس لا يعرفون ان هذا المشروع
الذي يتطلب تمويل ضخما في البدايه اذا بدا
بانفاق المملكه العربيه السعوديه
عبد الوهاب المسيري في في مرحلتين في
حياته
مرحله استاذ الادب الانجليزي المقارن وهو
تخصص الاساسي وثانيا هي المرحله الذي بدا
يتم فيها بالموسوعه ثم بعد ذلك اخذ منحا
يجمع ما بين الكتابه
العلميه
والالتزام السياسي
وهو امر واضح في كل الكتابات المسيري
هذه الموسوعه الوحيده في العالم العربي
الان اللي هي في الحقيقه تصد هذا الفراغ
هي
تسيء اولا هي ليست من عمل المسيري بمفرده
للتاريخ يجب ان نعرف ان الذي كتب هذه
الموسوعه هم طائفه من الاساتذه المصريين
وبعضهم من غير المصريين وكان فضل للمسيري
في انه جمع هذه الطاقات ووظفها في خدمه
هذا المشروع اخذ المواد او الابواب او
المداخل التي هي موجوعه موجوده في
الموسوعه اليهوديه
وتخير منها ما رايه مناسبا
وتدخل هو في بعض المواضع التي تحتاج الى
ان تكتب بوجهه تضر عربيه اسلاميه مثل ما
قام المصريون في المحاوله الاولى لترجمه
دائره المعارف الاسلاميه فقام بعض
المصريين بتعليق حيث ما راوا ان هؤلاء
المستشرقين قد قد ارتكبوا بعض الاخطاء او
فاهم الامور بشكل فاذا هذا هذا جوهر مشروع
المسيري
وبعض مدته بعض الماده في هذه الموسوعه
تحتاج في الحقيقه الى مراجعه والى فضل
البيان ولكنه كتبها من منطلق فكره اساسيه
الخيط الناظم في عمل المرحوم المسيري هي
محاوله تعريف اليهود وفق العباره
المفهوم الرائج في علم الاجتماع المعرفه
وهي ان اليهود هم جماعه وظيفيه
هذه يعني بدون ان تفهم هذه الفكره فكره
اليهود كجماعه وظيفيه
لا تستطيع ان تفهم روح الموسوعه الموسوعه
الموسوعه اليهوديه
وبطبيعه الحال
اليهود كجزء من مشروع مشروع استعماري في
المنطقه العربيه وان هؤلاء تاريخيا كانوا
يقومون بهذه الوظيفه وظيفه
الجماعه الوظيفيه حتى داخل تاريخ اوروبا
الوسيط ونحن هذا نعرفوه في في بطريقه
معينه في تاريخ العلاقات
الاسلاميه اليهوديه والاسلاميه اليهوديه
المسيحيه والقرون الوسطى لان هؤلاء اليهود
مثلا جزء منهم كانوا يسمون باليهود
الرهادنه
الرهادنه والمفرد ورهدان
وهؤلاء اليهود الرهادنا واحنا في اللهجه
التونسيه هو الرجل الكيس
هو الرجل الذي
يظهر ما لا يبطل
اردت هؤلاء التجاره هادئنهم الذين كانوا
يشتغلون بين الامبراطوريتين الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه الامبراطوريات الاسلاميه
والمسيحيه وكانوا يشتغلون بالتجاره
والترجمه
نظرا لحاله الصراع بين الامبراطوريتين
فهؤلاء تخيروا هاتين المهنتين وتمكنوا
وتمكنوا من ان يكونوا همزه الوصل بين بين
هاتين الحضارتين
وبطبيعه الحال تاريخيه المعروفه انه مقدمه
كبار كبار المترجمين في القرون الوسطى
واشتغلوا بهذه بهذه الوظيفه لانه الصراع
الحقيقي في لم يكن بين المسلمين ويهود
اليهود لم يكن لهم اي وزن لا من الجهه
المسيحيه ولا من الجهه
الاسلاميه الصراع الحقيقي كان بين الاسلام
والمسيحيه صراع عقائدي او الجوانب عقائديه
كبيره
وهؤلاء اليهود لم يكن لهم كيان سياسي يجعل
من المسلمين او من المسيحيين
يكونوا مصدر خوف ولذلك كان عمله
بين هاتين بين هاتين بالنسبه لموضوع
المسيري سد فراغا هائلا عليه رحمه الله
ولكن بطبيعه الحال هذا الامر يجب ان
يتواصل يجب يتواصل بافضل تركه تركه
المسيري احترم في المسيري التزامه الوطني
والقومي والعروب والاسلامي وانه حاول
اناره العقول بخطوره المشروع الصهيوني على
العالم العربي
واعتقد انه ادى الامانه فيها في هذا الباب
واعمله ككل اعمال البشر يعني فيه اشياء
تستحق التصويب ولكن ادى كما قلت ادم عليه
من امانه الكبه والسالفتها يعني الرمزيه
فيها الكبه هي انه اليهودي يرى
تدعوه الى التواضع يعني دائما هناك فوقك
فوق كل ذي علم عليم فوق كل
يعني احدى تفسيرات الموجوده في